the newly pardoned michael flynn has
pushed
on twitter a call for donald trump to
declare
martial law because it is preferable to
civil war
this website it's called the we the
people convention
goes over all of the things abraham
lincoln did
yeah you got you got you is there an
issue luke we're counting no no no what
are you doing we got luke
he's chilling here we're not in martial
are ready
i'm wondering about uh but not yeah no i
wasn't saying anything i'm just waiting
for you
oh yeah oh yeah he's got causing trouble
yeah i would i didn't do nothing
michael flynn is pushing uh uh pushing
out these tweets
so we talked a little bit a little bit
about this yesterday it's the weather
people convention
where they've gone over all the things
that abraham lincoln did
abraham lincoln did some messed up stuff
so aside from this we'll go over this
we'll talk about what's going on arizona
gop
did a very small sample size of
duplicate bouts found
two of the votes out of a hundred were
from were flipped from trump so
it's hard to know if you can really
extrapolate that up to two percent but
that's significant in a small sample
size so they're saying we need to do
more
donald trump put out a 46 minute video
where he was basically
putting out his case to skoda saying you
got to overturn this give it to me
that doesn't seem like some i don't i
don't see that playing out
we also got some statements made by
obama the squad is mad at him
the left is saying obama isn't left
enough we got some
uh we got a staten island uh staten
island bar owner just basically defied
cuomo and de blasio got arrested
people are starting to stand up you know
when they shut down people's businesses
in march with this coveted lockdown
people are like okay i'll play by the
rules people got nothing left to lose
anymore
so we're going to talk about all this
and like i mentioned it's it's luke
rukowski of
we are changed he's hanging out howdy
i'm the ravelrouser in chief of we are
change.org
i like long walks on the beach and i
think i'm the only person that has ever
been to uh the bilderberg group and
jeffrey epstein's island
and talked about it for some reason a
lot of people go
but coincidentally they just don't say
anything which is you know
i think you're one of like there's a
there's a small handful of people
outside of
the wealthy creepos who's actually been
epstein's island yeah yeah
that's crazy that you went that's nice
and jeff berwick the dollar vigilante so
uh hey it's i just did what the
mainstream media should have been doing
the mainstream media was driving around
boats
and they're you know just you know
taking videos of the outside and i'm
like why isn't anyone stepping in on the
island and seeing what was going on
there why was this not investigated and
we have to remember
jeffrey epstein was an individual that
was promoted by the mainstream media
mainstream media publications were
rewriting puff piece
releases by him and they were literally
uh promoting him so it's just absolutely
insane
you're a crazy guy and you're also what
was it your your alex jones's his
adopted son is that what it is uh
i heard putin i think is a little bit
more accurate yeah you do look like
putin there's a lot of theories out
there
oddly enough uh i'm not that big of a
theorizer i just like to question
different things i like to investigate
different things i like to ask questions
and
uh i've been able to share that through
my youtube channel which i've been
having a lot of fun through
and uh also for the record i've known
tim
before decade before i think anyone even
knew who tim was i think before anyone
even knew what a beanie was i
knew tim hole wow for that long over a
decade
started to occupy just about a decade
yeah i mean it's been it's been a long i
remember
we i went to occupy and you were sitting
with some chick and we were like talking
about stuff
and then you were like i could make a
video about what's going on at occupy i
got 50
000 subscribers and i was like wow
really yeah wow crazy
that's so big yeah i remember those days
and they were incredible and i think
i think there there was something that
happened on occupy wall street that
really kind of scared
the establishment because we saw all
people from all different walks of life
leftists uh right wingers libertarians
ron paul people a lot of people who are
just
you know sick of the big banks sick of
the multinational corporation
sick of the politicians lying to them
not keeping their promises
and then just essentially coming out
into this one
small little park and the energy was
there there were celebrities coming down
the media refused to cover it but it was
so easy to get rid of it all they did
was they sprinkled in a little identity
politics and then the whole thing ripped
itself apart well i remember
you and i think my first impression was
when there was a little
sub meeting during one of the occupy uh
it was it was a general assembly shadow
group trying to take over yes there was
a shadow group trying to take over
and i remember meeting tim for the first
time and there was these like communists
there who were like
okay guys we're gonna do sparkly fingers
and we're gonna make the communist
manifesto the mainstream
occupy wall street and i'm like uh-uh
nope and then and then you were at the
same meeting and you're like nope not
gonna happen and you're like we gotta
talk about that and i'm like yeah and
then and then i was like
yeah this guy gets it this guy actually
knows i mean let's go
what's going on no no no it was it was
it was essentially the communist
manifesto so so
uh let's before we got we gotta talk
about this it's gonna be fun and then
we'll talk about michael flynn but ian
of course is still sitting here trying
to make sure we intro ian and lydia of
course
i was also at occupy and uh was it one
of those like back where they go to the
the ho the apartment complex and they
all sit in a big circle no they just
went like two blocks away like an alley
so here's what they said they were like
initially
at occupy wall street you had there was
some i remember some old people like
probably in their late 60s
sitting in lawn chairs with a big
american flag and they were talking
about
the banks ripping everybody off the
revolving door politics and a need for
change it was a very populist uprising
people
all walks of life then these young
people started coming in one of these
groups
they were saying the message of occupy
wall street needs to be
free college and guarant
like they were like smaller class sizes
but free college
and i was like wait that would mean
you'd have to like exponentially
expand college buildings to guarantee
every
it makes no sense they were they were
actually proposing things that were
contradictory and i was like this is
going to make the whole thing fall apart
and then there was that lady who faked
the seizure remember that cecile i think
her i'm not going to name anybody i
don't want to get sued
but she you know yeah it was a yeah
there's a whole lot of arguments and i
remember seeing meeting tim
first for the first time ever there and
like that kid knows what's going on
and tommy's and i was like essentially
that's what they were proposing well it
was it was that there was it was
interesting there was unity
early on there were like conservatives
and and socialists being like we need to
stop the overpower
the power from these big bangs it was an
incredible place where people could
actually talk people could actually
debate
people from all different political
spectrums came together
and they're like okay let's show let's
actually work this out short-lived but i
think
it was it was incredible because it was
the first time ever there was a populist
kind of uprising that the mainstream
media tried to fully ignore
but because of the internet because of
individuals like you
lorenzo the occupy media team and you
know i was there of course as well
documenting everything on the ground
people saw something that they weren't
getting on the mainstream media that was
very interesting to them
that resonated with people and that's
why we had so many different celebrities
so many different philosophers so many
different thinkers staged debate stairs
and conversations that were
absolutely rewarding and but you know
what then you know the natural
consequence of occupy was
at least in part donald trump bernie
sanders
you had right-wing populists left-wing
populists sort of moderate economic
populists nationalist populists people
who just said for the people by the
people not the elite the establishment
revolving door bs
and so you go from 2011 eventually
occupy got dominated by
leftists but a lot of the regular there
was a lot of regular traditional liberal
types moderate lefty types
they flipped for trump so when you had
this
uprising sort of this this emergence of
these populists
and then it came to political candidates
populist bernie sanders emerges populist
donald trump emerges well guess what
donald trump is he i don't know there's
a lot of words people use to describe
him
but i think tough is probably a good one
you can call him you can call him stupid
small hand orange face whatever
but the dude is stronger than than these
people on the left yeah
and bernie sanders couldn't hang so he
gets knocked out donald trump ends up
winning
yes he has that tough personality that
people naturally
are kind of attracted to but he also
plays up
his anti-establishment more than anyone
else
even though sometimes he has people like
john bolton right next to him what is
stupid
which is not a smart move to do but but
he's able to play up on
uh you know his charisma his personality
and when you truly go to one of his
kind of talks whenever he's doing one of
his rallies it's really an event
that's kind of awestunning and you
really kind of do understand a lot of
people don't understand donald trump
unless they actually go to one of his
rallies one of his meetings
and you really get to see how he's up
there in the moment and
he's a comedian to everyone he's funny
he's funny he's legitimately funny
i think it was dave chappelle that was
talking about
how donald trump came up with the term
kung flu
and he was like i'm not going to curse
here but dave chappelle kirsten he was
like
you know i'm not i'm mad at him he said
that not because it's racially
insensitive
but that's something i should say not
donald trump right
and uh yeah you got you kind of kind of
give it up to him in that way
where he does represent this kind of
anti-establishment
idea but it's an idea but yeah he's not
as smart as sanders they weren't
they weren't afraid of him like they
were of sanders like donald trump put
they were donald trump with that what's
his name bolton in now he's threatening
to repeal
section 230 completely that's crazy lead
insanity
like he doesn't know what he's doing no
but you know what i kind of i'm kind of
digging it you know why
well if the result is either uh if like
if 230 got repealed but he didn't
reauthorize the ndaa i would just be
laughing the whole time
now i'm concerned about our military
personnel for sure but the things they
stuff in that bill the amount of money
they waste the no bid contracts
trump's like i'm not going to sign the
nda unless you repeal 230 i'm like
he's just gonna blow it he's like
blowing the whole thing up like he won't
see
it's him literally pointing the middle
finger to the political establishment
and the military-industrial complex
and it's hilarious i don't know much
about the ndaa i don't i really don't
but i
like at a service level i would love to
not refund it it seems like a
so trade act well it funds the military
it authorizes the the expenses towards
military and and we spend a ridiculous
amount of money
i was reading there was a tweet matt
taibbi tweeted something out saying that
when you actually break down the costs
even half of republicans agree this is
ridiculous
we're spending too much money and i
think the easiest way to put it is we're
building roads in afghanistan and iraq
or we've been for 20 years and it's kind
of winding down you know with trump
why are we doing that here we're
building infrastructure in other
countries
it's just it's 20 years of my life we've
been doing this we need to get
tanks from west to east over there yeah
i had to drive down from
upstate new york holy cow that looked
some places looked like
iraq down there i mean the roads yeah
and i'm driving a trailer so this
thing's jumping up and down all the time
but
the military industrial complex does
feed off the american people
more than any kind of communist
socialist leech out there you want to
talk about
corporate welfare holy cow when you look
at no military contracts yeah no big
contract how can
like where's the free market where's the
where's the capitalism when you have
lockheed martin and boeing
literally siphoning whoa whoa whoa whoa
those companies are run by women luke
you're a sexist star and the new lgbtq
friendly mainstream media approved uh
groups they're gonna put rainbow like
they're gonna put rainbow flags on
hellfire missiles
i'm i'm not even there's a photo of this
like people were pointing it out like
this is what their plan is it's a it's a
reaper drone and they put the symbols on
it like that makes it okay yeah it's
absolutely ridiculous or joe biden's
gonna have fancy socks that's what we're
gonna have
with the mainstream media coming up in
the next four years fancy joe biden
socks
and look how great this person is drone
bombing a wedding in yemen
uh but they won't even talk about that
or how you know the united states is
with al qaeda in yemen and that's a
whole other
donald trump discussion could run into a
burning building to save a box of
puppies
and they would criticize him for being
reckless and endangering
well he as much as we're critical of him
he is the president this is
extremely reckless no matter what he
does it's bad
donald trump literally killed american
citizens people don't know this
i ran as much as i can i remember you
asked it was you you asked was it
charlie gibbs
yeah obama's spokesperson and one of his
top cabinet members
me and sierra adamson during the
presidential debates when
barack obama was running against mitt
romney went up to him and he
and we asked him a question that no one
asked ever
why did you kill an american why did you
and this is important to understand here
barack obama physically signed off on
every drone strike
physically made the approval for sending
out
killer robots to drone bomb innocent
people 90
of which were found out according to the
intercept with the government documents
that they were able to find
90 percent of which were innocent
civilians
so you know when you have such an
egregious case especially
with the case of a 16 year old american
citizen
from colorado that was assassinated
under this deposition matrix
it's not this position yeah disposition
matrix you know they they make up all
these fancy words for it
it's assassinated yeah it's a kill list
it's a killer that's essentially it is
barack obama granted himself the
ultimate power of
fewer able to assassinate and kill any
american citizen
anywhere in the world now at any time
under his own decree
no court no judge no lawyer no legal
arguments
and he did it and he carried it out now
here's what here's where it comes in the
ndaa
so donald trump tweets out unless they
repeal section 230 i'm going to veto the
national defense authorization act
that's crazy it's really crazy i mean
repealing section 230 would destroy the
internet no joke like
it would be the end of independent media
right cnn will be laughing all the way
to the bank because they got lawyers
they can afford it
now smaller channels definitely can
independent media definitely can't if
230 goes
this channel won't exist youtube will
start banning everybody left and right
youtube would become netflix overnight
where they sign off on every bit of
content
and they want it so a lot of people said
this is trump's big ask right
he says repeal 230 that way they walk it
down to reform no
no no no no the democrats the
establishment the
the rhinos the never trumpers they're
begging to get rid of 230
because the only challenge they've ever
had is when the people were able to
communicate with each other and they've
been desperately trying to ban people
give them an excuse so now going back to
obama obama signed off on something
called the indefinite detention
provision
it was added to the national defense
authorization act i think in what 2012
yes it allows the government to
indefinitely detain anybody
anywhere for effectively any reason even
american citizens
obama signed that so now you have in
this country
what 80 million people they say who
voted for biden assuming that's you know
the correct and final number many of
whom
don't know anything about the democratic
party don't know what uh obama was don't
know what biden was
and now they're cheering like we did it
we defeated fascism it was like yes the
fascists who was pulling our troops out
of these countries who was
drawing down our are you know started no
new wars great now we're going back to
the obama
era yeah it just boggles my mind to to
see so many people call donald trump a
fascist he's a fascist meanwhile where
were you during the obama administration
where he legally codified
assassinating spying torturing killing
executing any american citizen at any
time
that he wants to and these are the
powers that he gave
donald trump and now there's other
people telling donald trump hey use some
of these powers
let's invoke martial law and it's just
it's just
i think i think director yeah i think
we're being played
uh like a fiddle here i think it's
important to pay attention more than
ever
and these issues especially the obama
administration we need to revise
what happened under obama because this
is obama 2.0
slash more corporatist of a presidency
coming in with joe biden
joe biden who argued that there should
be more corporate lobbying inside of the
white house
not less so that's the major
disagreement that obama had with bayern
biden wanted more
so special interest but something
interesting is going to happen
in their desperation the establishment
tried to activate as many people as
possible to vote
so i'm talking to my friends now and
they're like you know i know this guy he
posted a picture of himself voting you
know he's dropping the mailbox or mail
in ballot
and i was and he was like you got to
vote for biden everybody and so i you
know challenged him a bit like why
and he's like you know trump is is
undermining our democracy and said all
these things
and then i just went through a list of
obama era you know policies where biden
was the vp and he's like well i don't
know about supporting all that i mean i
wasn't really paying attention back then
and i was like so will you acknowledge
you voted in a guy who oversaw
his brother and family getting rich
flying his son on air force two to get
this equity deal
and blowing up kids and now but here's
the point i'm gonna make
when you say where were you when obama
was doing all this oh they were asleep
and you know what i'm not gonna drag him
for that but guess what
if you think i'm gonna sit back and and
joe biden gets to come in
and start blowing up kids again blowing
up you know uh innocent civilians 90
drones striking and trump was doing
drone strikes too i criticized him for
that
i'm gonna i'm gonna hold these people
figuratively to the flame
i'm gonna be like wow you supported this
this is great so tell me now how do you
feel about these kids yeah
trump not only uh you know supported and
continued these policies he also got rid
of the provision
that made the reporting of him not
existent so we still don't know
exactly what donald trump did because he
got rid of that but one of the videos
that i'm most proud of that i did before
was during a presidential election where
i went up to random people and i read
off obama's policies but i told them
that they were mitt romney's policies
and i'm like mitt romney wants to
assassinate american citizens
mitt romney wants to spy on you mitt
romney wants to torture american
citizens
and mitt romney and all the people all
the people that are interviewed and i
was like this is romney and then they're
like this is horrible we got to stop it
we got to fight him
and of course these are all barack obama
supporters and then at the end of the
video i'm like well actually i got to be
honest with you i lied to you
these weren't these weren't the policies
of mitt romney these are the policies
that the guys you're voting for and
supporting
and you know but there's literally this
is tribalism man yes it's all true party
politics tribalism to divide and conquer
agenda that's being
laid out that makes people hate each
other over these little imaginary gang
rules that are just absolutely
ridiculous and insane so let's talk
about
michael flynn this we the people thing
we did bring it up a little bit
yesterday so we'll we'll sort of segue
off this into trump's call for victory
you know he's calling for this goat
he's calling on scottish giving the win
before we do man i didn't even say this
subscribe hit the like button hit the
notification bell you may have noticed
we changed the cameras a little bit
yeah yeah and we're going to change them
a little bit further we're just kind of
making things better and better as we go
along
but again subscribe live monday through
friday at a uh live monday through
friday at 8 00 pm
and again smash the like button so check
this out we have this tweet
general flynn flynn uh said hashtag we
the people
he tagged sydney powell and wood dance
gavino lou dobbs maria bartoromo mark
levin
and lof who's low fly i don't know who
lufla is just uh oh okay proud wife of
an american hero
and then it is the press release from
the we the people convention if you
didn't see this yesterday
this is a call for donald trump to
declare martial law
to enact a new election and a lot of
people are saying that's that's crazy
it's unconstitutional
how would he even do this and what
they're saying is trump needs to have
a new election paper only secure poll
watchers and all that stuff
i don't think i don't think it can be
done right now
what the we the people convention are
saying is martial law is preferable to
civil war
so they're they're basically saying if
trump does nothing
we're gonna have civil war what's
extremely likely well if trump declares
martial law and says
joe biden didn't win then we're gonna
have civil war i just there's no way
around that
yeah i mean absolutely i mean my my uh
kind of pro
my solution to fix this problem is to i
mean i don't know why people aren't
talking about this let's break up the
country in two
you like a government you like joe biden
divorce stay on one place yeah i mean
what what what the cities leave yep no
this you know these represent themselves
and people who want to be under one
government will be under one i think i
mean i i think
really we're headed towards a very
dangerous situation and i think the only
way to avoid
getting it it being even more uh
worse for everyone is to just simply
walk away from it i think we're at it i
mean i guess time
we saw what john podesta was suggesting
that it would be better for joe biden to
uh for the west coast to secede from the
union yes
than to allow donald trump to win they'd
get invaded immediately
if the city tried to secede they'd get
invaded by the united states
any any of those states tried to succeed
oh absolutely they'd be occupied in two
seconds
and then it would just like there's
actually been conservatives calling for
that saying
remove the local leadership the
politicians and just put it under like
territorial rule
like revoke their statehood and like
it's getting crazy out there man
listen mike i i could understand why
michael flynn is
is retweeting look you know you go you
pull some of these websites and they're
like
michael flynn calls for martial law and
things like this
it's like well they're pushing this this
idea that you know
we can be careful in that i understand i
completely understand why michael flynn
would be saying this
they they railroaded the guy they they
threatened his family
plead guilty to this bs charge or we're
gonna go after your kid
and then when when trump got inside
we're getting rid of this they were like
no
judge sullivan refused to allow them to
drop the case it makes no sense
and then he was sitting and waiting you
know why sullivan was waiting and not
just saying fine we're gonna rule on
this
because he was just gonna wait it out
until biden gets into office and then
say okay we're back on track flynn
you're going to prison
so trump issues that pardon flynn's
livid and he says
do it i get it because he went through
the corrupt process
and is there going to be justice should
that shouldn't that judge face some kind
of censure or impeachment
what about the what about the fbi agents
who who threatened his son
and said we're going to prosecute your
son unless you plead guilty all of them
get away with it
so of course he's coming out and saying
trump shut it down
yeah i mean michael flynn definitely
didn't have any friends in washington dc
when he was coming into power with
donald trump he's one of the few people
that actually whistleblowed
on the us whistleblower
us agencies financing uh
jihadis in syria he's one of the few
ones that was inside
of obama's administration that released
information and said
it's because of barack obama it's
because of hillary clinton why we have
isis and that was east
and that was retribution yes it exactly
was right
there's no other way to to really see it
because when michael flynn came out i
was talking about
all the you know important information
he was you know finally
confirming because i've been saying for
a very long time especially since there
was this kind of quote revolution in
syria
this kind of liberation that hillary
clinton was supporting of the syrian
people
when that was happening i said wait wait
wait wait hold on why is saudi arabia
israel the united states all working on
this one side why are the rebel groups
being financed and armed here who are
these rebel groups
there are al-nusra they were al-qaeda
and then they became isis
as well that was financed the only
person inside of the government that
actually confirmed it that actually
spoke out against it was michael flynn
trump when trump picked him to be a part
of his administration
this is this was one of the reasons i
was like that there might be some
legitimate change here because michael
flynn
is at the helm of national security of
american foreign policy there's a chance
that we finally
might revert some of the horrible
foreign policy decisions by hillary
clinton
then he didn't even get into office
because of why
why because of the espionage act an act
yeah yeah the logan act that wasn't used
against someone
ever for for how long never never used
exactly and and then
the his charge officially was because
kushner told him
to contact russia so russia would vote
favorably with israel it's not it's not
that it's not
no no that's not even that's not even it
there was an excuse
you know uh based on the notes that were
released throughout this investigation i
think i think it was coming from durham
i'm not entirely sure
no i don't think it was i don't know
where these files were released from it
shows that
it was possibly joe biden who suggested
the fbi use the logan act
the logan act basically says that you
as a non-government agent can't act as
though you are representing the us
government
no it's never been used before because
it's a it's it was in it was written for
a time when there were no telephones
now a guy shows up and says hey i'm an
ambassador they call the number and this
is not get out of here
michael flynn was the acting national
security advisor for donald trump
he was coming in he had a phone call
with kislyak the russian ambassador
and he said don't please don't escalate
sanctions
you know let us come in and try and work
things out that was it
that was his job he was supposed to do
that so they threatened him that's the
logan act
yep so they there was an informal
meeting with like hanging out at the
white house
not a legitimate investigation informal
meeting
and they asked him do you ever talk to
kislyak and he said no no and they went
got him he lied
they went to him and said can uh confess
plead guilty otherwise we will go after
your son
notes that got released from the fbi
showed that the agents were asking
what's our goal here to prosecute or get
him fired
now why would the fbi just be trying to
get a guy fired this was retribution
from barack obama i didn't i didn't know
that about flynn and all the beans and
then it's very important
to understand here how the mainstream
media was reporting on this when it was
happening they were like
confirmed russian collusion we have an
active case michael flynn deserves to go
to jail i mean what what did michael
flynn do he called the russian
ambassador
right before getting into power well he
was the acting national student
yes i mean and like biden right now is
calling up world leaders talking to him
if you're going to charge michael flynn
for that crime you're going to have to
charge joe biden if we're going by the
law by the definitions of how you
enforce them
so that's something that people really
need to kind of pay attention of course
they're not
of course you know you have joe biden
literally studying up there talking
about
you know all this nonsense well literal
president's elect
behind this isn't he getting a cat joe
biden's undoubtedly
yeah he's getting a cat a german
shepherd look man luke i i respect that
you're so
passionate about you know children being
murdered and
and corruption at the highest levels and
our patriots like michael flynn being
falsely targeted and imprisoned
but i think i need to point out joe
biden was playing with a dog you know
he's got
nobody wants to hear this no no no no no
go go to sleep i appreciate your love
america and that you care about people
and want to protect people but
biden is getting a cat yeah yeah i mean
that's what's more important here my
one of my favorite lines from uh uh
who i'm forgetting his name bill hicks
bill hicks
here's american gladiators what is it
here's 47 channels of it
yeah here's uh you know distract
yourself america
uh go back no no george carlin also said
go back to sleep america because the
only way you could have the american
dream is
to be asleep bill hicks said go back to
bed america your government is in
control again yes
yeah yeah amazing comedians that that
line
sums up everything that's happening i
didn't know that about flynn
yeah he's legit so there's no dude he's
he's he's a weird character because he
also has a very strong kind of war
policy towards iran
yeah but when it came to being inside of
the obama administration he's one of the
few people that actually spoke out
against some of the very wrong
doings that obama was committing when he
was working
for obama i actually talked uh to you
know general wesley clark
about you know very these very kind of
similar issues and it's absolutely
mind-boggling to see how everything
operates general wrestling clark was one
of the few people inside of the
government that came out
on democracy now and talked about this
u.s plan for larger
war right what do you name like seven
countries with seven countries and the
u.s police syria yeah u.s foreign policy
was literally
going too long i talked to u.s general
leslie clark i was like
you know thank you so much for warning
us about you know this coming there was
you know something that didn't always
you know you weren't a true fortune
teller but
most of what you said is coming true how
did you know what's going on
are you scared that you whistleblowed
and and talked about this plan for all
these wars
he looked like he just saw a ghost he
turned white and he was like ah
and then he walked away and ran away and
didn't say anything and it was just
another awkward we are change kind of
interview
yeah we have a lot of ambush ambush
questions but
they're trying to put central banks in
all these countries it's like is that
what they're doing
that's why they went into afghanistan
that's a different theory out there well
now there's central banks in afghanistan
and iraq
um iran doesn't have one syria didn't
have one it doesn't have one
libya didn't now it does uh no iran
doesn't have one so
what doesn't happen north korea doesn't
have one if if one of the biggest uh uh
one of the talking points coming up now
is that everything trump is doing with
like the dod and stuff
is is an attempt to ramp up going
against iran
yeah i mean start a war before he leads
or something yeah the israeli military
there's scuttlebutt that they're
preparing for the u.s to
you know start a war with iran but again
it's just scuttlebutt nothing has been
officially confirmed we have seen very
aggressive moves by donald trump against
iran that there's some people theorizing
that donald trump may start a conflict
with them
to stay in power to stay in power and
all that i don't think that's true i
hope it's not true but again i haven't
seen it
certified with any legitimate
information backing that just a lot of
speculation and theories but we don't
have to speculate we don't have to
theorize what's going to happen with joe
biden all you have to see
is his whole career in politics but also
his actions as vice president under
barack obama who made very telling
statements today
that are absolutely mind-blowing i mean
there's another madeleine albright it
was worth it hundreds of thousands of
children
died similar statement by barack obama
about this kind of assassination program
that he had which is let me talk let me
pull this up so i got this tweet from
luke
at luke we are change just a video of
obama explaining how he had to stop
himself from killing innocent children
this is from cbs it's an interview with
stephen colbert
it happened recently right it was a
couple days ago yes here's the best
thing
so seeing this and seeing this interview
i thought wow there must have been a ton
of journalists who wrote this up like
look at what's going on joe biden is
obama 2.0 he's appointing a lot of the
same people it is going to be a disaster
so i googled it and you know what i
found i googled cbs drone obama
the rap ufo yes barack obama knows the
ufo answer but he can't tell you
obama compares trump to dictator okay
yes there you go it's absolutely
ridiculous but just to
tell you what barack obama said his
exact quote was the problem with the
drone program
was not that it caused an inordinate
amount of civilian casualties
although even one civilian casualty is
tragic but the drone
probably had less collateral damage and
then he went on and talked about how he
was using this
and how there was a problem of how he
saw it as not even
war and how he was deploying it very
casually without even
thinking about it and how he needed to
set up
particular measures to stop himself from
sending out drone strikes all over the
world we have to understand
seven countries were attacked under the
uh
barack obama administration somalia was
also one of those heavily hit secret war
going on in somalia now apparently cia
agent died a terror attack well i was in
somalia
and uh i'll tell you what's happening
there
is absolutely mind-boggling modeling i
was able to talk to
victims of botched u.s raids where
innocent farmers were pretty much
assassinated because of bad intel and
bad information
now the the somalia conflict i mean we
could do a full two hours
just about that and that issue
particularly but i just ended up there
randomly because jeff berwick the dollar
vigilante he's like an anarchist
he he keeps saying that uh everyone
keeps
accusing him of of not being a real
anarchist and if he is a real anarchist
he should go to somalia so he did so
he's like i'm going to go to somalia and
he was like you want to come i'm like
yup
we went to somalia and it was a surreal
experience and
uh surprise surprise it wasn't that
there was a lack of government
the problem was that was that there was
too many governments inside fighting
vying for power uh you know middle
eastern countries were involved
turkey was involved qatar was involved
africom was involved
the united states was involved and they
were all sending in and shipping
in weapons munitions and then soldiers
that were hired that were supposedly the
good guys were
started selling them for food because
they didn't have food so it's a total
mismanagement and a total conundrum of
just
absolutely what the hell is going on
when you go to somalia when you talk to
some of these individuals
they are resilient they are amazing
human beings i was able to
like talk to people who were severely
affected
by major terrorist attacks by al-nusra
by major attacks by the u.s military
that killed their family members
and it's it's something else when you
really go to these countries and you see
the full effects of american foreign
policy and you stare a farmer in the eye
as he tells you and shows you all the
family members that your tax dollars
financed
that executed them so so so let's talk
about this uh in 2016 we'll talk about
uh the question is should donald trump
get another four years
and so he he you so trump uh wait we
have this starter
let's just jump to the article and then
i'll get to my point quote it is
statistically impossible that i lost
white house releases 46-minute address
address by trump
complaining that he lost the election
and pleading with the supreme court to
overturn biden's victory
they say the president posted a
46-minute video he complained about
voting machines and bouts that came in
election night
predicted what he was saying will be
demeaned and disparaged
said he didn't want a re-vote but wanted
to overturn the election immediately
he called the election a total
catastrophe trump said it may be the
most important speech i've ever made
in 2016 coming off of the obama
administration
man i was just so like i don't even care
this is
you know this stuff is going to keep
happening it was bush now it's obama
what is it going to be hillary trump
whatever they said hillary was going to
win i didn't care i'm not going to vote
because i didn't see trump as being
particularly better
when trump got in for the first about
two and a half years or more i mean he
was upping drone strikes there were
commando raids in yemen
there were civilians dying and i was
like here we go again
59 missile strikes into into syria but
something started to change
later on he fires john bolton he starts
saying the american people don't like
this
we're going to get our troops out of
syria we learned that
there were officials u.s federal
officials who lied to the american
people and donald trump to keep our
soldiers
in syria that's insane donald trump was
elected
to to end the forever wars partly he
didn't do a good job
initially he started to improve so i
decided you know i'm going to vote for
the guy now
the question is knowing what we're going
to get with joe biden
what we'll first talk about should trump
get another four years
then we'll talk about the fraud
accusations the things he brought up and
and your thoughts luke well you brought
up a very good point
especially with what donald trump was
promising because when he was running
to be president of the united states one
of the main ways he galvanized so many
people
is by saying he's anti-war he wants to
bring the troops home
everyone rallied behind that everyone
was excited about that it was
it wasn't just hope and change but we
also have to understand barack obama
campaigned on those same things
promising bring back the troops
stop the spying stop the torture george
w bush
same thing promised to be a
non-interventionist and look at him
starting the iraq war so with
everything that's kind of moving forward
it really makes you wonder
is the u.s president that that powerful
i know it's a very kind of symbolic kind
of gesture but when we look at
everything kind of moving forward
we're definitely putting ourselves in a
very peculiar situation
that's not an easy one to figure out so
how we're going to move forward
it's it's really going to be something
that i'm i i can't figure out
we're going to do you think trump did a
good job in the past couple years
did he do a better job i i think he
definitely did
i think i was i was definitely
entertained by by his rhetoric
uh but but i think he he fell short i
think there's still a lot of individuals
like julian assange that would say that
he did a very terrible job since
many of his policies led julian assange
many of his actions let julian assange
to still be
in in you know jail right now extradited
should be part and snowden should be
parted and i think personally ross
ulbricht should be uh pardoned
as well and you know if i was donald
trump right now
if if i was him if i was in charge i
would keep all the promises i made i
would send all the troops home
i would end the war on drugs but hold on
but i would still
try to do it at least on pen and paper
right so then
when joe biden comes in he has to
authorize them he has to convince the
american people saying
no we need the war on drugs no we need
uh julian assange that we need
the troops in peace this is why you know
donald trump
there's a lot of there's a lot of
lefties hate the man and i was i was
surprised i thought one of the one of
the possible
outcomes of the 2020 election would be
that progressives would be like i don't
know i'll take the anti-war guy over
biden but nope nope
they came out they said they wanted
biden because a lot of these people are
young and don't know
like we had we had one guy on he was in
a teenager during occupy wall street he
doesn't know anything
about this stuff so what we end up
happening
what we're going to end up seeing now is
joe biden is going to get in
and he's going to reverse a lot of
populist policies
that the left probably does like he's
going to go nuts on war
we're counting down the days i love it
i'm looking at these anti-trump reply
guys who all of a sudden are anti-biden
they're i'm like oh here you go you
screamed about trump maybe these people
are just contrarians yeah naomi wolf
just realized oh there's going to be
more lockdowns for this
biden regret and people don't understand
i mean some people say biden's not there
he he he maybe isn't but we have to
understand he still is a front porch
front person for the military industrial
complex for the pharma industrial
complex for the prison industrial
complex
all big businesses all the corrupt
institutions all the multinational
corporations
are behind him joe biden just says
whatever talking points
he's assigned to and he's been doing
that his entire career
you look at the issues whether it's
segregation if it was popular
he said it oh he was for it but not even
not even when it was popular when it was
the status quo and the establishment
approved
those talking points so whatever the
establishment wants he is the front
person of that
and he didn't even have to promise to
bring all the troops home
he didn't have to promise what barack
obama had to promise what
what donald trump promised he didn't
even have to do that so that's something
that really should wake people up to
what's coming in the next four years
because
he's not even promising to be a good guy
he's he's not even doing
press releases he's not even doing press
conferences he's not even speaking to
the people
he's just this mystery weird guy who uh
mumbles is donald trump
the greatest president of your life your
lifetime ah he's
i i think you have to say yes man
politicians we're comparing him to other
presidents i gotta say
he is substantially better than every
president i've lived through
politicians are like i'm i can't curse
here are like buttocks
uh they're all full full of crap but
some of them have a better diet
yes donald trump at least with his
rhetoric at least with some of his
nationalistic kind of policies is a lot
better he was able
to shake things up he was able to rattle
things and and that i will give him
credit for
when it comes to julian assange when it
comes to some of his foreign policy
i have very serious questions about he
called himself a patriot and a globalist
and i think his presidency exemplifies
that he said
himself yes he said i am quasi i forgot
the exact
terminology and wording i could actually
look it up here uh but he said he
he compared himself a globalist and a
patriot trump did yes
interesting uh which which is what he's
been he's kind of been flip-flopping
where he's hanging out with henry
kissinger one day and the second day
going after china and their trade
policies
when you have kissinger the guy who
literally opened up china to the world
if you look at the conundrum that
america and the world is facing with
china
those have the direct fingerprints of
henry kissinger
david yeah well well fired this
larger kind of institution part of the
advisory board for the pentagon which is
now
on his way out i know and i'm like so so
here's what a lot of people are
questioning
why is trump making all of these moves
like replacing the pentagon leadership
sending uh his acting secretary of
defense says special forces now
answers directly to me and bypasses a
bureaucracy then he gets rid of this
advisory board when i when someone sent
me a message they were like trump fired
kissinger i was like what and i looked
it up i started laughing it was yeah
you sent me that article i'm like wait
what do you mean what yeah
and you know the guy is still kicking
the guy still
such you know didn't he like call for
genocide before or something
well when you look at his policies that
he was able to establish under nixon
under the vietnam war specifically in
cambodia specifically in chile
specifically in
third world countries where he was the
kind of architect and
an engineer of this larger term of an
economic hitman
so if you look at john perkins and the
economic hit man and the revelations
that came out of that book
it's henry kissinger all over it the
world bank the imf the same
organizations calling for a global reset
now
were some of the same institutions that
were hand in hand working with kissinger
working with the united states working
with the cia
intelligence agencies overthrowing
governments setting policies all around
the world
and when you see a lot of the
detrimental horrible things that have
happened
whether it's war whether it's
multinational corporations abusing lying
poisoning or doing anything
a lot of them point back to directly
those kind of individuals that need to
be called out so here's the crazy thing
right you know during occupy wall street
you had the left
protesting obama in 2016 the left didn't
show up to protest the rnc
they showed the protest the dnc now
for some reason they voted for for for
biden i guess
but what's going to happen now is going
to be so weird because
i was they were like tim pool's a
leftist the whole time like during obama
and everything
then donald trump's elected and i'm like
the media is lying about it but the
leftists align themselves the
establishment so then also people start
calling me conservative
now i'm telling you when i start ragging
on biden i've been ragging on biden
my friends i've ragged on obama and
biden endlessly for the past decade okay
now they're gonna be like what's gonna
happen
who's gonna be left who's to be right
yeah what's the right wing it doesn't
matter anymore
i rag on everyone because i think they
all deserve to be ragged on
uh anyone in power i believe in total
decentralization that's my own kind of
philosophy but i i think there's a you
know
a statement from donald trump that's
really going to be poignant here with
what you were just saying when he said
antifa is going to have their way with
joe biden they're going to eat him for
breakfast
did he say have their way it's not an
exact quote i'm ad-libbing here
i don't have the exact words but
generally he said
that anti-fuzz is going to you know take
down joe biden and
i you know right now we're not seeing a
lot of anti-protesting
a lot of the stronger government
restrictions and lockdowns
well they're pro lockdown yeah weirdly
which is they're like
we stopped fascism yay okay government
now what oh you want us to be forced to
stay in our homes
yay we defeated fascism yes we want
checkpoints yes you want us to shut down
all the private and small
businesses to help out walmart and
amazon it's absolutely
exactly right we want to talk about what
fascism is yeah but
mussolini said the merger between the
corporation and the state for
you know for the mutual benefit or
whatever now what do you got going on
there's a guy in staten island who he's
not like i'm watching this guy on tv
and i mean no disrespect but he's not a
tv guy he's not a public figure out of a
person he's a regular guy
and so he's not giving you that polished
politician answer they're like why are
you opening your bar and defying these
lockdowns
and he's just like we got to do
something like they're they're
destroying us
it's like we have nothing left and they
pointed something out it's really crazy
the staten island story
they said this bar where the guy defied
the police
the police line up and blocked the
entrance these cops are nuts they were
like two blocks away
everything's normal restaurants dining
totally normal
what happens is de blasio just decides
this is a red zone and they put on the
ground
with like it's like paint or something a
sign saying danger zone or something
it's the creepiest thing
just segmenting off parts of the city
saying your business is done
it's it's it feels like mafioso
like what their goal is hey uh my name
is bill de blasio
cuomo come over here we're going to shut
down this part of the city so that all
the all the property value collapses
buy it up he said he was going to do it
bill de blasio said he was going to do
it i have to say uh bill de blasio
really loves to graffiti the streets in
europe of new york city
he seems to really have a knack for that
uh and it's just absolutely insane like
you won't be able to walk down to
another street or another block or
another neighborhood
the new york city subway system is still
open and operating and in many instances
crowded with a large number of
individuals when you see
you know you know the como brothers when
you see the politicians
when you see them defying their own kind
of rules and decrees
like if you want people to take you
seriously you should take
what policies you're proposing what
policies or decrees you're pushing on
people you should follow them
as well and they're not they're openly
celebrating
biden's victory they're openly promoting
black lives matter protest because black
lives matter protests are
essential and way more important than
the conhole sickness
uh and it's absolutely ridiculous that's
that's listen yeah
this is why i think we i i you know i
used to say like man we're about to go
over the edge huh
i think we went over the edge a long
time ago we were falling for a long time
we hit the ground like there's no going
back from this
for a year now we've seen democrats
flaunt their own rules
they they say oh no we got to do all
these things and then they go to the
opposite nancy pelosi gets her hair it
gets her hair done gretchen whitmer lori
lightfoot
then they do the lockdown again saying
things are getting so bad we got to lock
everything down and then newsome goes in
parties with a bunch of doctors
in a closed room and then he's like that
was a mistake then all of these
democrats are flying to hawaii for
vacation
they're laughing in the faces of those
and they're destroying the lives of
working-class people
and where is antifa nowhere to be found
they were screaming that there was a guy
with an orange face and then as soon as
the orange guy leaves they're like okay
we're fine with the fascism now bye
yeah cnn goes after people who make
memes that are
against them and doxes them meanwhile
when you see a legitimate threat against
the livelihood of individuals this poor
guy he's trying to
make ends meet he's trying to make a
living he's trying to make sure his
employees
have a paycheck so they they could
actually eat they could actually live
in one of the most taxed regulated
controlled cities in all of the united
states
and you after buying by all the laws
after doing everything you're supposed
to do this guy also had
a pretty good idea i have to say he
declared his business in
autonomous zone just like chas and he
says well this is
an autonomous zone because again when
chas first started this was nothing that
was questioned nothing that was stopped
by the authorities
nothing that was uh you know brought up
as a health hazard of individuals
camping together
staying together in close quarters
without proper
bathroom facilities no one even talked
about that but you open up a business
where you want
to make a living for yourself and this
is the first of its case that i saw here
in the united states where it actually
led to
an arrest right this happened recently
in toronto heaven and jersey
uh well people gym owners yes the gym
owners were
there was the salon owners arrested yes
yes i remember even uh you know
that was i was i was at that gym i was
talking to the main gym owner of
a friend was actually uh grew up grew up
with him
uh and was a was a high school friend of
them and
what what happened to them and what
happens to individuals it's mainly
individuals who are standing up
and they're raising their voice about
how insane how unjust how unscientific
how illogical
a lot of this is and because of that
they get targets on their back and the
government sends out police officers who
don't question
anything who many times follow decrees
these are not laws
right there's not even even debates
these are not even laws that are
codified
you're not just him ordering his
praetorian guard to go abuse the
the peasants yeah not based off science
i mean if you really do
care about our personal well-being you
know maybe we could have a conversation
about proper health
proper sleep proper diet proper exercise
making sure that we're not stressed out
gun safety training
mandatory gun ownership yeah universal
universal gun program where the
government has mandated to give everyone
a gun
i like that idea from the gun the
department of gun services dude diet's
huge obesity's
insane epidemic high fructose corn syrup
is just insidious the way that they're
injecting this stuff into our population
let me ask you though you're from new
york right
i moved from new york this year and i
moved and i moved up to the
live free or die state new hampshire has
been an incredible experience let me ask
you uh do the police in new york swear
notes the constitution
um i'm not sure if they do but the cops
do that
there's this duty to serve and protect
but legally
the new york city police department
argued in court many times that they
have no duty
to protect you to help you
or to do anything to you or for you and
this was exemplified by my friend
joe lozito that literally took down a
mass
murderer there was a mass murderer on
the loose police officers saw that this
mass murderer was on the loose they were
inside of a train car
watching as joe lozito was being stabbed
joel
watched yeah i met joe lozito you know
through a friend i became friends with
him and he told me this story i saw the
scars on his head randomly at a bar
and i'm like my goodness like i i need
to share your story
and uh yeah i mean he had a butcher
knife
stabbed in the head almost lost his life
bled out everywhere after taking down
the killer joe lozito took down the
killer badly injured
police officers only after he was taken
down came out of that subway car
and then they handcuffed you know the
criminal and they waited and they
and they even derailed uh the the train
from
moving because of official protocol
which made joe lozito bleed out he woke
up in the hospital
with mayor i think it was bloomberg at
the time congratulating these two
officers
that stood back as heroes who took down
a murderer and they called him a victim
he sued
the city the city argued we had no duty
to protect you as you were getting
stabbed as we had guns
and clubs and could have stopped this
man almost killing you we didn't have to
so what you're saying is
defund the police
i mean again there's other examples we
could talk about
such as charon that i personally
traveled to which are these autonomous
kind of uh zones where there are no
police where there are no governments i
think
there is everyone's got guns security
well they live
in their own uh land
thirty thousand people in tehran where
they
decide what they're going to mexico
themselves yes it's in michio khan it's
in one of the deadliest states of all of
mexico
that is reporting no debts after
the population rose up with small arms
with pitchforks with knives and
throughout
the cartel the police department and the
government that were all working in
tandem
and now they're living more prosperous
than ever there hasn't been
a murder in that town for i think seven
years now i did a full documentary
traveling down there 30 000 people uh
yes they're armed you have their own
guns of course
people don't get what's the point of an
occupation a military occupation you
want people to give you something you
want to control the land for some
strategic resource
or you want the people to give you a
portion of their labor and resources
you want stuff you want it from them
what happens if they all
say no then occupation gets you nothing
what can you do if the people won't give
you what you want so it's not even about
small arms it's about
just defiance at a certain point you're
like it costs me more
trying to get these defiant people to do
anything they won't do
these people on the left they don't
realize when they talk about you know
insurrection and revolution
civil war whatever the second amendment
that's meaningless because the
government has you know cruise missiles
and it's like bro
read your history i'm laughing in
vietnamese yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
tommy right tunnels that's what the
vietnamese did
giants it's just about having people say
no say no
look right now if everybody in staten
island nah
what are they gonna do the cops are
gonna be like we can't do anything yeah
that's it they have to bring in these
cops from outside these areas to enforce
this stuff too because
they'd be like their their aunt would
come out with a you know rolling pin and
being like what you doing get out of
here you know
so they bring in guys from other parts
of the city and they move them down and
they have them enforce laws that nobody
nobody wants and it's crazy to me that
even though you have this guy in staten
island he defies this
they're all still doing everything by
the appropriate cdc guidelines
they're just not shutting their doors
and then the cops come out
anyway let's let's let's do this let's
talk about defund the police because i
want to talk about antifa with you
because you brought it up earlier we
have some we have some amazing antifa
stories i want to tell the story
but so barack obama apparently is no
longer left enough we have the story
from the independent
it's not a slogan ilhan omar fires back
at obama for attacking defund the police
campaign
we lose people in han in the hands of
the police
says minnesota representative so obama
basically comes out and says
you lost a big audience the minute you
say it which makes it a lot less likely
that you're actually going to get the
changes you want done
he's actually right the former president
said in an interview obtained by axios
the key is deciding
do you want to actually get something
done or do you want to feel good among
the people
you already agree with mr obama added
ellen omar tweets
we lose people in the hands of police
it's not a slogan but a policy demand
and centering the demand for equitable
investments and budgets for communities
across the country
gets us progress and safety a bunch of
other squad members you know came out we
got
a newly elected uh corey bush saying
with all due respect mr
president let's talk about losing people
we lost michael brown jr we lost brianna
taylor
we are losing our loved ones to police
violence it's not a slogan
it's a mandate for keeping our people
alive defund the police
they don't want uh they don't want the
middle ground
they don't want regular americans and i
tell you you know who's gonna who's in
for a rude awakening
regular americans the ones who voted for
biden not the ones who voted for trump
they're gonna be forced to see this
stuff now they're gonna see the dark
winter
you know joe biden says we're in for a
dark winter the regular americans
who went out and said orange man is bad
because cnn said so they're not gonna be
happy with their decision
because obama isn't left enough the
squad is saying you're not left enough
sorry we're gonna defund the police what
does it mean to defund the police
oh they say no no we just mean we'll
take some of the money away from the
cops
and then what do you actually hear new
york times op-ed
yes we mean abolish the police it's
absolutely nuts
it's funny in minnesota they voted to
defund the police
and then crime skyrocketed people
started freaking out and also these city
council members were like no no no go
back take we
want to take you back he takes you back
like we don't want to do it well cops
are
fleeing the city they don't want to work
there so now this is what you get
under abiding i'll tell you what's gonna
happen with biden and with anti-fun all
the stuff
things have kind of calmed down and
people are saying see now that biden's
won antifa kind of going away trump was
wrong well it's winter
this is a normal thing that happens in
winter people stop protesting as much
it's getting colder out the leaves are
gone
we'll see how things play out i think
biden
is going to try and throw them enough
red meat
to keep them satiated but he really is
snubbing these progressives
bad oh yeah 100 especially with his
appointees for his cabinet
his transition team is fue filled near
its hand
with the worst of the worst swamp
monsters that you could ever
imagine from the corporate globalist
international world
of cd investment banks and hedge funds
that are essentially robbing this
country blind many people don't even
know that there's massive
federal reserve bailouts of hedge funds
happening right now
that's going to happen on a larger scale
under the obama
sorry the biden administration which is
going to be filled with a lot of
corporatists now i could see
kind of obama's statements as a kind of
strategy
that he's trying to deploy trying to
galvanize some people behind
joe biden trying to trying to get this
middle ground
but i think what you're saying is
absolutely correct there's going to be a
very rude awakening to a lot of
individuals who are saying
yes we got out trump but who did you
replace him with
and it's just like that meme where one
person tears down a statue and another
statue just pops right back up that you
have in your song
that i'm thinking about right now and no
but but trump wasn't the same like
it is true they tear one down the next
pops up but trump would have been
better the economy was was fantastic and
he was on the policies on china i feel
like the economy was just
tanking this whole time only during
covington we have to understand there's
a big difference between the economy
and the stock market so just because the
stock market's doing good
doesn't mean that the average american
the the the average american was doing
really really well in 2019.
2019 sure but i'm talking about right
now a record number
that's democrats uh shutting down the
economy
interest federal reserve interest and
debt that's why the economy
is is inflated basically right now so it
looks the numbers are big but the value
of the dollar
is down the stock market makes people
yeah the stock market's inflated right
it makes their retirement accounts look
good
20 22 of all u.s dollars were printed
this year alone no way yes and there's
going to be more printed
and so buy your gold hide your wives
hide your kids
look at the cryptocurrencies maybe uh
you know i've been talking about
a very long time but that's you know
this that's a separate topic but
it's going to be a very interesting
transition
i understand where you're coming from
and i could see some of the very
populist very the
the popular kind of policies by donald
trump especially his policies against
china which are going to do a hundred
com 180 degree flip right now under
obama
under a biden administration which of
course is going to be
very favorable towards china and that's
going to have tremendous ramifications
like it always had
ever since henry kissinger and david
rockefeller opened up china to the world
and made it
the manufacturing slave hub of the world
for the benefit of the multinational
corporations
that are you know changing out middle
class blue collar jobs in america
and then just sending them off to china
that kind of
policy that has been abusing the average
american that has destroyed
cities like uh you know detroit that has
destroyed
this ability of one family member being
able to work for an entire family you
know it used to be
that one person would work in the family
and they would they were able to make
ends meet
now uh you can't have that now the the
mom and the dad are both working jobs
and struggling to make ends meet exactly
and the kids got to be in school
otherwise they can't work so then they
shut down the schools
forcing the kids in in defiance of the
science i mean i tell you these these
mayors these governors
they're trying to destroy people's lives
on purpose yeah and there's no science
especially you know in new york city
backing that keeping kids in school is
somehow a danger where's the logic
where's the
the data where are the studies where is
the logical kind of conclusions coming
towards saying hey having you know
children in school is dangerous there's
i haven't seen any uh there's nothing
justifying it and it's having a huge
huge effect on this poor guy in staten
island that's
essentially getting destroyed getting
put in jail
getting uh you know robbed and
essentially you know ransomed because he
doesn't want to give away his profits to
walmart and to amazon that's his crime
his crime
is not bowing down to his new corporate
overlords and people need to understand
that as the main principled issue here
he didn't violate any made-up laws and
decrees he just didn't go along with the
establishment program to finance the
beast
that is the corporate giant in america
the world economic forum published a
video where they said
in 2030 you will not own anything and
you will be happy
and they have they are now saying covet
19. so they published that was a couple
years ago
now they're saying copa 19 is our chance
for a great reset they're very clearly
exploiting a crisis
to destroy ownership because they don't
want you
to be sovereign and autonomous they
don't want you to be the individual who
says i don't need government they want
you dependent on government
they want you begging the government for
a stimulus and it's working
yeah so they're going to lock you up
because they own you
that's their plan last i thought this
was america
yeah and once you're dependent on
government to survive the government has
more power and control over you and
that's why it should kind of raise
eyebrows that we literally have
the gates foundation the imf the united
nations the world bank
the world economic forum and many
multinational corporations talking about
the great reset at the same time the new
york times is telling you it's a
conspiracy theory
so as that is happening you really have
to wonder what's going out there and the
only way to really get
you know this kind of greater
understanding is on youtube where
a major battle is you know happening and
a lot of these messages are
just getting squashed out we were we
were joking around
before the show the other day and i said
a funny idea
for a base like a dystopian novel is the
government
mandates everybody gets heroin but only
the government can produce and
distribute it
if you act in defiance of the law they
withhold it so now you're literally
going through chemical withdrawal
shaking begging saying please i'll do
anything i'll do anything
and when you finally submit to their
demands they give you the drug
so heron was just basically you know
something that would cause a
physiological
withdrawal symptom in you something make
you freak out that's basically
it's it's an analogy for what they do
they make you dependent upon them
then once you are they say do as we say
or else and people are like okay
okay i'll do i'll do whatever you say
just please give me the money and give
me the food
in cities you can't grow your own food
what are you gonna do go on your roof
you own property probably don't own
property
so people are dependent upon having this
job you got to get out of these cities
man
you got to get out of these cities well
you can't just grow your own food but
you can't also just
start a business it's becoming more and
more difficult because of
the blue tape because of the government
officials because of these bureaucrats
that are running around
and they're literally making sure that
small businesses
independent businesses are finding it
absolutely impossible
to actually get a fair shake at the
market we don't have
capitalism right now we have top down
socialism
for the super rich the super rich are
being financed in ways that we couldn't
even
imagine especially when you look at the
federal reserve bailouts that are
happening right now
especially if you look at amazon walmart
they don't have to follow any of these
ridiculous roles they're allowed to be
open they flaunt
you know their businesses everywhere
they're promoted i was talking to a
young kid at the grocery store that was
bagging the groceries
and you know we were just you know
casually just you know
talking about well you know you have to
do what you got to do
you know we got to keep everyone safe
and i'm like did you ever wonder why
you know you can't have thanksgiving but
you could have black friday and he's
like
whoa i never thought about that i mean
and it's absolutely ridiculous to see
these politicians
rage a war on family members coming
together and eating together
as one cohesiveness in the box store is
but
i was in new york city for thanksgiving
visiting family
i went out to best buy literally
lines down the block garages filled
individuals standing next to each other
touching the same door touching the same
products all cuddled in together
and that somehow gets your stamp of
approval that's okay but
gathering with family is is not and i
think there's a huge
another thing that you were talking
about the kind of corporate overlord
control of being dependent on government
i think another key pillar of that is
breaking down the family unit
which not a lot of people talk about
yeah black lives matter is a part of it
as they had
previously on their mission statement
direct disrupt the modern family yes to
disrupt the modern family
when you have traditional families yeah
traditional family when you have a
traditional
modern family you have something that is
a very strong unit
that's not easy to control or dominate
or take advantage of you have
individuals that help each other out
that are there for each other
and are strong they want you like that
uh
like that magazine cover it's the borg
yeah they want you
sitting alone with that cat surrounded
by the new boxes
drinking your sorrows away disconnected
from the world meanwhile you're on
the you know the the internet in this
digital little box
that you get to kind of lose your
identity to
black mirror dude yeah that's exactly
standard stay in your box
yeah and that's what they want and
whether this is done because of a grand
conspiracy or whether this is done by
accident it's happening and it needs to
stop and we need to have a real
conversation
about how to prevent it and i think the
family unit i think
culture i think that's the key elements
here that we need
we absolutely need to take advantage of
didn't donald trump want to appoint some
lady who wanted to uh
he tried to appoint some lady who wanted
to get on the gold standard yes and then
they block they're like no get out of
here
yes so so incidences like that i could
totally understand
the the trump optimism i had some of it
myself
uh and i think that was an amazing even
though he didn't get it through it was
still a symbolic move that makes people
believe that there's something
possible that that something could
change and i think if trump was that's
important if trump was going along
with all of these plans he'd have won
they'd have they'd have been like we
support him oh yeah
you know well the mainstream media
wouldn't be attacking him for every
little thing whether it's two scoops of
ice cream or having toilet paper
on his uh shoe they wouldn't be
attacking him so
viciously if if he was so that's another
important element remember when he fired
those missiles in a syria and they were
like trump is acting very presidential
now yes
how many people how many civilians did
he kill brian williams talked about how
beautiful it was to see these missiles
fly through the air i mean
how sick and and of a despotic
individual do you have to be to be
celebrating
the war machine and to be in awe of
missiles flying to bombs
that's the national anthem is explosion
explosive bombs
in the air that's what we celebrate as a
country it's crazy
isn't it isn't that about the revolution
that's when we were under attack yeah
yeah yeah we shot us defending ourselves
and fighting for us
bombs bursting in air man when you're
talking about people coming here
to to oppress and suppress and attack
they don't kids don't know that when you
when kids sing bombs bursting in air
they're getting indoctrinated dude no
listen sure
then it's your responsibility to make
sure they understand defensive versus
offensive
who's responsibility everyone
no you tell them now it is your
responsibility to ensure the next
generation has a good opportunity for a
future it is our
it is incumbent upon us the the current
array of adults to be like kids
here's what you need to understand we
don't want to celebrate
firing tomahawk missiles into into a
foreign country
we want to celebrate us standing up
against the largest empire in the world
saying
fu those are our bombs get out of our
country
because we're a country of people who
say leave us alone let us do our thing
who do you consider the largest empire
in the world now
i mean arguably the u.s but china's
poised to take over
what china is doing in africa and south
america oil exploration
the the property they're buying up china
owns huge swaths of western land in the
united states
they're buying up property all over
brazil it is absolutely ridiculous
and canada as well i remember being in
africa and there was a bunch of just
chinese people all over the place and
i'm like what's going on here i was in
kenya zimbabwe and some
colonization there was chinese people in
somalia looking for economic
opportunities there
and and i talked to a lot of local
africans and all of them came up to me
and and
the larger sentiment from the vast
majority of them is that the chinese are
the new colonizers
they're here well they're taking over
and they are so it's literal
colonization
in china the conditions are getting bad
there's a lot of pollution there's a lot
of carbon emissions smoke
you know that famous photo where they
have the screen that has the sun on it
because it's just brown
all day with just smog so people
naturally
are emigrating and this is modern or
some i guess they call it neocolonialism
it's not like the government says we
want to send boats out and take over the
world
it's regular people in china saying i
want to find a better life so they're
moving to all these different parts of
the world
and their culture is is is you know
rooting in these places
and for the most part it's fine but when
when kovit breaks out
the chinese government sent out a
message sent out word to a lot of their
citizens
buy up ppe and send it back to china and
they did
so they started extracting our resources
from our communities
because they were lying to the world
health organization lying to us
and then when covet hit we didn't have
the supplies we need we've been giving
them our manufacturing base and you know
what it is
it's an exploit and it's the fault it is
it is a weakness
of the american system politicians are
in on the take
professors are ending the take it is so
easy to just say this big corporation is
going to going to lobby on my behalf
and they probably got some international
connection but the politicians don't
care
they just say give me the keys at the
castle i want to be rich and famous i
want to have some my mark in history i
don't care about you your family or this
country
that's why you end up with politicians
that literally don't care
and would see us enter the trans-pacific
partnership when you take say like the
greatest empire i want to hear what you
think
well i have a couple points i definitely
want to add to what you were saying
there tim because
it is scary that they're buying up
industries and taking over
but it's also really scary to see the
impact that they have on our modern
culture
on our entertainment and our news when
you see
the slanted coverage when you see the
manipulations when you see
the world health director not even being
able to recognize
taiwan when you see hollywood movies
censor out
any kind of criticism any kind of even
hypothetical fight with china
or or when a hollywood movie actually
draws the south china sea as territory
of china in their film remember that
exactly and we have to understand china
is an expanding empire and one of the
reasons they're
they're expanding is because
geopolitically they are in a poor
position
this is why they're expanding to the
south chinese sea
this is why they're using microwave
weapons on the indian border right now
in disputed territory because they need
to expand their empire because
historically
they have always been conquered because
they are stuck on this one
land mass there's a lot of desert there
isn't a lot of natural water there isn't
a lot of natural farming land
they're literally re-engineering an
entire huge section of china to be
farmland
turning it from desert will it work who
knows but they
lack a lot of resources this is why
they're doing the belt and road
initiative that's the new silk road
this is why they're building military
islands so if there is a potential
conflict they have these trade routes
they're in charge of them and if you
look at major world wars they have
always had
they have always happened listen with
trade routes this country
welded people's the the communist party
they welded people's doors shut during
covet
and then later on opened them up and
there are the people lying dead on the
ground
that's what they were doing they were
they were like there's videos of them
dragging people screaming out of their
homes
they're an authoritarian communist
regime people can't speak freely they
live
under the boot these people want control
of everything
and the question i ask people is in 50
years
on the track we're on china will be the
dominant global culture
would you rather live under a chinese
system or an american system
well most people say of course american
system for all it's false
okay that means we have to do something
right now
because they're buying up land all over
the planet they're buying up resources
they're stripping us of our resources
during pandemics what do we do
if joe biden all the money joe biden
becomes president
we know he flew on air force two to
china with his son
which is already a huge conflict of
interest negotiating some chinese
private equity deal
why would joe biden go against his
business partners well not his
personally
as the wall street journal said there
was no role for joe biden
but is joe biden going to screw over his
son who has this
this beautiful equity deal out of china
no look at
was it lebron james i think is that is
emma call out the right guy who was
basically defending china yeah
you look it was it steve kerr these nba
guys were like well i don't know a whole
lot about china i mean if they want to
you know
put a bunch of weaker muslims in
concentration camps you know they want
to make money
that is the exploit the nba says we make
so much money in china it's so big
we're just gonna say you know whatever
and we're gonna agree with their
despotic authoritarianism
china right now is operating
concentration camps no joke
no lie no exaggeration they're
harvesting organs of people
joe biden gets in what does he say well
they're not our enemies no we're gonna
work with them
right doing their thing he's going to
get us into the new team
it's the new the new tpp i forget what
it's called
and you are going to see your factories
ship over to china faster than you can
faster than you can blink because what
joe biden's talked about is
raising the corporate tax rate and they
use this leftism lie
to convince people a good idea why are
these corporations come on man
pay your fair share why aren't they
paying their fair share what's their
fair share 39
so you're a corporation you got a bunch
of employees and he says here's what
we're gonna do
minimum wage and your for your company
is going to go up by 30
also we're going to raise your corporate
tax rate by up 10
up to 39 percent now these factories are
going like what are we gonna
we can't make ends meet and then he's
gonna go don't worry if you make it
overseas you can ship it to the country
for free
no tariffs no taxes free trade and they
go
okay thank you thank you okay let's uh
let's move to china
the the there's the cheap labor no you
don't got to pay for unions
you don't got to pay for health care
these people breathe and smog and
they're getting sick
and you ship it all back to the u.s free
so for super super cheap
made in china baby that's biden and you
have to realize companies like apple
nike most of the products you buy on
amazon all made in china
some accusations some reports are coming
that it's coming from forced laborers
coming from
oh and they don't remember that and
there are lobbying efforts
by a lot of these multinational
corporations to make sure that they
could still continue the practice of
receiving goods
that are made from slaves that are made
from political dissidents
that are made from individuals who who
jaywalk i mean what's happening right
now in china especially with the social
credit score many
globalists many internationalists many
politicians are seeing and they're
salivating at the mouth
many of these practices have already
been duplicated here in the united
states in democratically heavy cities
like new york city
los angeles and we are seeing it being
carbon copied
in very scary ways where even in new
york city the the government there is
tracking you through your cell phone
data to make sure that you quarantine
and texting right now if you come out of
state i mean
is it this is listen this is why donald
trump has to win you want
you want to hear it i got it right here
no no lydia just pulled it up
u.s bans cotton imports from china
producer xpcc citing xinjiang slave
labor
the trump administration expanded
economic pressure on china's western
region of xinjiang
on wednesday banning cotton imports from
a powerful chinese quasi-military
organization
that it says uses the forced labor of
detained uyghur muslims
nightmarish yep and that population is
going extinct they're missing no one
knows
yeah well they could sell them on the
international world market and you know
who they sell into
the people who need halal organs yeah
well yes so very wealthy individuals in
the middle
east they say i need an organ transplant
and it can't come from anybody
so they have the uyghur muslims and
china's been doing nightmarish things i
mean this is
re-education camps uh total control
great society
the video that came out with them in in
uh they had bags over their their head
they were all wearing the same uniform
they were all
kneeling down their prisoner transport
they said yeah i mean that was
absolutely horrifying and i remember
being in hong kong
covering the protest there with emily
and you
felt this huge oppressive state and
these people
fighting for however whatever way they
could
against it becoming there but things we
have to realize the people of hong kong
actually fought back
at china in influencing them and taking
control over them
here in the united states all the large
corporations all the mainstream media
are cheering it on
clapping for yeah when you're wanting it
while saying they're a part of their
resistance
and they're part of the protest i mean
are you freaking out it's really it's
really simple
there are photos of people in hong kong
waving trump flags and american flags
and there are people in this country
waving communist flags yes
real quick sorry just yeah i love the
meme where it's like can we trade like
all the communists
go in china you want to you know bring
these people into the party
and then we'll take the people in hong
kong who are like go trump go america we
love freedom right how about that yeah i
love the people in hong kong they are
absolutely incredible i have to say like
my experiences covering those protests
have been absolutely
life-changing they know i mean the way
that they acted
i mean they even you know did stuff that
you know
you know it's questionable but the way
they acted
is so different than antifa you know
antifa
usually if they see a reporter filming
they beat the crap out of him they
arrest him they try to intimidate him
they scare
him whatever it is there they just had a
whole bunch of people holding umbrellas
and if they were changing outfits or
doing something that was deemed illegal
by the chinese state
they just put up a whole bunch of
umbrellas everywhere and they didn't
need to fight everyone because you
couldn't take a photo or video of it
no pushing no shoving no anger you know
and they made sure
that journalists who were reporting on
them actually got the story
you know they weren't trying to suppress
them they weren't trying to stop it they
knew
that getting their message out was
extremely important i remember walking
down during a very tense moment
and they're like this is press make sure
he goes to the front line so he sees
everything that's happening as literally
they were trying to take over the
airport
yeah and and here you would never have
that in the united states
and the way that they just you know made
sure that their optics were good which
is what they were doing
the way that they were they're fighting
is really something that
should be somewhat commendable should be
something that should be kind of looked
up to
and and replicated as something that
that is a lot better than what we have
right now with antifa
cheering on the multinational
corporations and beating the crap out of
anyone who dares question them
when they talk about international
relations and cooperation
when they talk about trump being
isolationist or nationalist
what they're really talking about is
they want the u.s to capitulate to china
period so there's something i reference
a lot it's called thucydides trap
this idea that as a rising economic
economic power is about to displace
the the current economic power war
breaks out and so one of the theories is
that the us is basically
saying it's better to lay down and roll
over onto
and expose our bellies to china and just
say just take it we don't want to go to
war because where would be bad for
everybody
china says okay so the question then is
which world do you want to live in
one where there are concentration camps
for the for religious minorities
where they harvest their organs and sell
them or or what a country like america
where we have those problems in the past
but now that that would never fly yep
but the left will probably cite the
the you know the native reservations no
no the detention centers baiden's even
proposed
secretary of state literally previously
made
arguments saying that the united states
should not step in the way of a rising
china
and that it's going to be beneficial
economically if china does rise and we
should help
and assist yes this is literally some of
the talking points
that are going to be exemplified and
done by this biden administration
empire um and you said the united states
and china is the two greatest empires
i'm thinking like where's the money
coming from because i think you're
talking about the bank of international
settlements you said the idea what do
you mean the money
like where's china getting their money
the federal reserve new york
they just fake it the united states is
getting it printing it fiat from the
federal reserve
and the chinese communist party prints
and manipulates their currency so
they're they probably i don't know what
their central bank is if they i think
they do have a central bank which they
all feed through the bank of
international settlements in switzerland
so the swiss bank i feel like is the
real empire and
that's why the media is being is using
the american military
to bankrupt well to basically enforce
the bankruptcy of the united states and
the
you know the disillusionment of and
they're giving chinese people all this
fiat currency to go buy up land all over
the world and probably oligarch
sometimes
zero interest loans that they're giving
to the chinese people to go up and buy
stuff and they are and it's unfair for a
lot of
other people but i would have to
question you on on that because
when you look at the larger geopolitical
moves that china has been making
especially with the lawn
especially with propositions for the sdr
especially with major moves against the
u.s petrodollar
you see a lot of significant uh moves
economically that
china has already been making so i do
believe we are already
in a trade war i believe i think we're
also very close to a currency war
and the next step is potentially
eventual war which i think should be
prevented at all costs
china wants taiwan they've been doing
beaching drills the u.s did there was it
called an elephant march or whatever or
elephant walk
well all the bombers were in guam you
know yeah military exercises
but then they were treated the us had to
retreat because they were like china has
a weapon that could wipe out all of our
our
our you know air assets yeah china is
literally conducting military drills
about their takeover of taiwan
near taiwan yep and then the world
health organization doesn't even want to
recognize taiwan as an official country
now that's terrifying because that's the
world health organization
not recognizing a country because the
country that
partly funds them or has a lot of
influence over them just doesn't want
them to exist and wants to take them
over
and one of the first things i said when
biden was you know allegedly the winner
is that
this is extremely bad news for the
people of taiwan
oh people of taiwan are in for very rude
awakening dude
china is going to storm the beaches of
taiwan and biden's gonna go
come on man yeah come on china's got the
pizza
people's bankers it's their federal bank
is the people's bank of china it's not a
federal bank it's their uh fiat
you know their central bank and then
that goes through the bank of
international they manipulate their
currency so that's all going through
this foreign trade
it's all going through swiss bank bank
of international settlements it's all
it's all
extra judicially like no government has
any oversight over this bank of
international settlements
and we have to understand it was global
elites henry kissinger literally wrote
the china policy that has codified and
put
us in this exact position so to have him
lobbying and and supposedly you know
telling
the presidency what to do here is
absolutely the wrong thing to do he's
making a lot of statements he recently
came out in
an expose talking about how biden needs
to be very light
on china this is again the same person
tied in with all the multinational
corporations all the inner elites
all the people i i have to say at the
part of the bilderberg meeting
that that come together that benefit off
of this kind of open
china this kind of manufacturing plant
this slave labor plant that makes
goods very very cheap this major
deindustrialization this major demand
factoring of the united states losing
these blue collar jobs was the beginning
of it
and it's only escalating from here and
has yet to be so they
look they came out and said the world
economic forum the davos group
great reset it's happening baby and it
is and and
democratic governors are doing it
they're defying the constitution when
the supreme court ruled
that cuomo could not shut down religious
services he said it's irrelevant
that executive order is expired so we
can do it we can do a new thing we can
do whatever we want and that's what they
do he'll make a new one
take me to court they'll keep doing it
the problem is the cops
who just say please cuomo can i lick
your boots
that's what they're doing there have
been some sheriffs speaking out against
it and haven't been following the policy
cops are different from the sheriffs
exactly but there are a lot of
individuals that are
absolutely just blind and are doing what
they're told and
imagine being a police officer and going
to a guy's business and putting him in
handcuffs because he wants to make a
living for his children
imagine that karma imagine having to go
through that now not all police officers
are bad
but there needs to be a big reckoning
especially with
this larger thing that has been
happening
all year long is is china locked down
right now no
they're doing huge parties yeah that our
economy is being destroyed
shut down not locked down people are
more free in wuhan china
than they are in new york city i don't
know i don't know which is which is
mind-boggling how are people more free
and wuhan than they are in new york city
yep
um and we have to another point that i
really wanted to
to kind of make here is for people to
understand that
you know a lot of this is is done
voluntarily a lot of these officers are
just saying yeah sure i'm going to take
the path of least resistance
that's how it always is just following
orders and
the main reason why there wasn't a lot
of support for the police earlier this
year
was because they were instituting a lot
of these ridiculous lockdowns and then
when the protests happening
when the riots happened there was a
factor of individuals saying i don't
care
these are the same officers robbing me
blind taking advantage of me destroying
my livelihood
because of a politician's decree bro
we're frogs in a pot
and oil boiling the water the water is
already boiling and we're sitting in it
and it is you know what i think it is i
don't think that if if i was to say
there's a grand conspiracy
it's just china trying its best to
subvert the us and they've been doing it
for a long time it's the global banking
establishment
using america and china against each
other no no
they're both funneling money through
china and the united states there are
there are wealthy
multinational elites that benefit off of
those countries international
settlements you got to look into it that
doesn't explain
china's military power and expansion
china's not beholding anybody when they
go and blow people up and lock people
that communist uno party is crazy
any any country that has a single party
there are communist regimes
i remember doing occupy wall street for
any any type of government if it's a
single party i'll
let me let me give you an analogy i was
interested by wall street there was a
general assembly meeting
and everyone's trying to figure out what
the real problem that everyone need to
fight was and then also some guy stood
up just
this old guy like in his 50s super angry
and went what is
wrong with you people it's fracking
fracking is everything and i started
laughing
like this guy has no idea what's going
on in the world he thinks
fracking is it when you talk about
the global banking establishment you're
talking about a handful of people who
are getting rich off of laughing at
those who are fighting each other not
the people controlling it so you're
talking about the bank of international
settlements you're talking about people
saying hey you guys blow each other up
as long as i can exchange the money take
a cut they're not in charge they're just
profiting off of it big time
they're they're the ones that are
loaning us the money china is the rising
power
that manipulates currency and puts
people in concentration camps to sell
sell their these people's organs and
they make our movies and they take our
jobs
and what they've been doing is they've
been compromising university professors
through their thousands
what is it called a thousand uh thousand
currents thousand currents
is it i think so no i i i look could you
could you fact check that because i
think the thousands are the professors
i think that's the black lives matter
organization thousand currents oh
talents thousand talents right what is
it so there
china is illegally giving grants to
professor at u.s
universities all over the place and mike
pompeo said earlier this year that china
has infiltrated every level of
government
so you've got university professors
lying getting us grant money to do
research
and then china pays them to share their
research with them
i it's it's that's that's borderline
treason but you could call it actual
trees and if we were actually at war
with china
they're they're they're not levying war
against this country so i don't know
subversion espionage whatever but there
is a trade war
happening and it's expanding and it's
only going to get so i tell you what
happens if trump doesn't find a way to
win
joe biden's he's all he's all he's on
board man he's going to sell out
the american people to foreign
corporations yeah more than we've
already been sold out but it's okay it's
okay you're going to have
your your you know triple thick
milkshake from mcdonald's we have to
replace as you're
as your family dissolves we have to
start our own well they're codifying it
with these lockdowns they're codifying
it by destroying
any power individuals have when we look
at these lockdowns they're also
happening in very democratically very
anti-second amendment states and i think
it's it's it's absolutely ridiculous
what's happening and we have to look at
this larger picture
of of what they're doing and the larger
consequences and effects of them and no
one's really doing it i think
i think i would not be surprised if
under a joe biden administration there's
a the union that's a fracture i mean you
you were talking about the country
splitting up
you look at south dakota south dakota
christie gnome she says we're not
locking down sorry shut up
joe biden said i'm gonna listen to the
science he brings on dr osterholm who
says lock the country down
nationwide lockdown six weeks what do
you think's going to happen when south
dakota says
no you're not doing it are they going to
send in the feds
what are they going to do well i think
the bigger conundrum the bigger
thing to really look at is some of the
gun restrictions that
biden wants to pass banning all online
sales of accessories ammo and guns
now when he codifies some laws that make
it
you know illegal or make americans
felons overnight when the democrats pass
it and then he signs off
yes that's why this you know this battle
that's happening in the senate is is
something that people should be looking
at it's very significant but that's also
going to be a major
major situation that again that's why
i've said let's let's split up people
who believe in government want
government want bureaucrats
and corporations ruling their lives you
go here you want to be responsible for
yourself you want to be free you want to
be an individual that makes his own way
that has their own destiny their own
faith
their own life in their own hands go
here it sounds like a crazy idea but
then
but what we have right now is absolutely
crazier and it's going to get
even crazier from here yes it's it's
these interests in the us
pledging fealty to china and saying we
want to we want to work like you do it's
so much easier just make us party
leaders
it's like the the invasion's happening
and they say well i could fight you
that's hard
i'll tell you what make me rich and i'll
sell out everybody else
they're swearing fealty to the dollar
man they don't care about any country
access it's it's the government is the
is money in this world right now that's
a good
you make me rich and i don't care what
you do to other people exactly
i don't care who my governor is if i can
get a tax break i mean so many people
think like that so many people voted for
trump simply because he made it
got him a tax break well government is
essentially a leech on the people
and that's how i see it as and i think
the more we move away from it the more
we become responsible for ourselves it
might be identical but i think it's
worth doing
i disagree if we had a country
that and a culture that was defending
the constitution
the government is is absolutely vital
and fantastic
if you take uh a a big open space let's
say montana
everybody flees these lock downs the
people are buying a property like crazy
in montana
uh idaho iowa new hampshire florida
texas
just well they're most most of the
property that we're seeing spike is in
like
middle of nowhere places wyoming montana
right these people go there
so let's say joe biden gets in and says
we're just going to keep doing these
deals we're going to sell you out your
job's going away
and then you've got people saying leave
me out of it i don't like government
who unifies and unites for the common
defense up against
china or when u.s interests are
essentially
like the nba like we had major
corporations in the u.s
basically saying we're sorry china all
like for the past several years
the houston yeah the houston rockets
apologized blizzard
one of the biggest video games
hearthstone booting some guy
because he had a sign saying you know
free hong kong and then
lebron i think it was lebron i want to
be careful i don't want to drag somebody
said something about how great china was
yeah yeah he repeatedly keeps defending
them so when that influence
comes into the united states where
they're telling you no no china's great
china is great
ignore what what they're doing one
problem is what without government
without a unified culture where we we
provide resources
and pool them for the common defense
there's no organizing a bunch of random
people you know what's gonna happen
people are gonna flee it's what's
happening now you've got cuomo and de
blasio
eviscerating new york state and city so
what happens
the people who who say this is wrong
leave they leave they're gone i left
you yeah i left i went to new hampshire
i love it there and it's absolutely
completely a hundred but this
is different than new york this means
they've won
they're violating the constitution in
that state it's been ruled their violent
constitution and they don't care
and there's no one there who's going to
challenge them who's going to sue them
they're just leaving
yeah she touched that she's there
actually that's true yeah she has she's
tearing things up people like hershey
too
yeah she was great he's fighting back i
want to point out about china that it's
really the communist party the ccp
that's the problem not the chinese
people and of course china gets a bad
rap
rep rather uh reputation that's what
that means a bad rep
uh and it's the ccp that's the problem
the chinese people are pretty awesome
they're just misinformed it seems like
well they're being they're under the
rule of a dictatorship dude that's so
crazy we've we've become
the united states became too complacent
and we started electing politicians
based on the d and the r
and that was exploited and now i don't
know if there's a way out yeah i mean if
you look at the cultural revolution in
china you look at the way that that
played out you look at the history of it
and you look at modern day history
holy cow i mean that's a big uh that's a
big
pill to swallow there and wake up so if
you have some time and you have
i mean i mean this is i think one of the
reasons why my
shirt says if you you know if you know
history um
if you trust government you don't know
history uh and and when you remember
when they poisoned
alcohol during prohibition and killed
all those people exactly
to enforce this asinine idea that
prohibition works it doesn't
i mean they were like people should
people are drinking our ethanol so let's
put methanol in it then people started
dying
to me yeah to me it all comes down to
either you believe
that that that there is a good
government that they're going to take
care of you or you believe in yourself
as an individual and i think those
individuals are exemplified those
individuals go into leadership
places and i think there is a middle
ground that we could reach that that
begins with an individual and i think
that's why it's very important for
individuals to look at farming
to look at alternatives to get to know
their neighbors to
stock up because i'm telling you the
next few months the next few years
they're not going to be that favorable
towards
uh people i don't know how else to say
it we are fear-monger but
it's already you know live nation i
think i think it was live nation or
ticketmaster saying
gotta get your vaccine status on your
ticket you want to go to the event
organizer's gonna say they want the
vaccine symbol on you on your on your
ticket
private corporations like walmart here's
here's my prediction
walmart's gonna say they're always
taking out you have to wear a mask if
you want to come in
you have to wear a mask you can't come
in you don't wear a mask the videos are
popping up where people are screaming at
other people who are not wearing masks
eventually when the vaccine comes out
they're gonna be like you gotta have
your vaccine app
you can't come without your vaccine app
you put on your phone you get your qr
code if you don't have it you can't come
in whatever just go get it it's free
it's free the
the government says they're going to
give it to you for free just get it
i i think vaccines are fantastic i think
they're wonderful technology
but i have concerns about this this
culturally mandated medication of people
for sure dude i just saw a commercial
about uh roundup that was monsanto's
flagship oh and it was like
if you use roundup call yeah 16 years
later
they're finding out that it's causing
all this cancer in people now there's
clash
class actually so a rushed vaccine i
mean 10 year what's what about in 12
years how are we going to see some sort
of repercussions i'm not
an experimental rushed vaccine that
big pharma companies are exempt from any
liability from
so so i'm sorry but if you're putting
your full fate into
that that's going to be mandated for
individuals i mean
it's going to be mandated by the
corporations like we saw the ceo of
qantas
recently proposed if you want to fly
you're going to have to have the vaccine
stamp
i mean again there's there's a new study
that came out that showed that 40
of health professionals in the united
states according to the cdc
are skeptical of this and plan not to
take
the vaccine to be reasonable uh when i
traveled to venezuela you have to have a
vaccine card because there's like yellow
fever
and like you know typhoid and stuff so
you go to go you gotta go to the doctor
they give you a card they approve it you
get your your vaccinations i'm i'm down
i think vaccinations are
are amazing we wiped out so many
diseases the issue i have is that if
within our own country you can't go to
the store
unless you you have to have some kind of
medication i mean that's crazy
we're not talking about airborne ebola
we're talking about 99.97
survival rate people under 70 are mostly
fine
and they want me to go get you know
medications politicians are saying you
need
this we're going to have the vaccine and
everything is going to go back to normal
that's not how it's going to work this
is again
experimental rushed there's two major
pharma giants fighting for this and if
they get
first to the market they're going to get
record amounts of
profits you think big pharma has a good
record look what they did with the
opioid epidemic
look at medical doctors telling you that
cigarettes are good for you
medical doctors about ddt look at dr
fauci talking about schools
you know look at donald trump saying
early on
the sign where the science is on our
side which the school should be open
and now fauci is saying oh actually yeah
they were right
don't wear the masks the masks you know
don't worry you're going to get more
sickness
now they're telling you what you need to
wear when mayor gave everybody aids
yes people forget about that bear owns
monsanto by the way what
was that story well they bought monsanto
and now they're a new kind of uh
company that's getting sued to oblivion
because they're finding out that roundup
uh
you know was linked to cancer and now
there's major record settlements of
individuals getting millions of dollars
and there's thousands of them coming
forward
with these recorded cancer cases showing
how bayer
lied and tried to cover up the fact that
they knew this was happening and when
they knew this was happening they
continued
and this is the same company that had
medicine that had
what was aids in it that they normally
knew and they said hiv they continued
to sell because they saw the profits
from it as
as less of a liability than actually
stopping of sending this medicine
there's an insane clip
of this happening and now you want to
trust big pharma when they have no
liability with this vaccine and another
thing to really consider here is
from cbs cbs bayer admits it paid
millions in hiv infection cases
just not in english this is from 2011.
whoa to read the english-speaking media
you'd never know that bayer just paid
tens of millions of dollars to end a
three-decade-long scandal in which the
company sold hiv contaminated blood
products to hemophiliacs
thousands of whom later died of aids i
am not saying
okay i am not saying the vaccine is
going to do anything like this
i am not saying the vaccine is bad i'm
saying in fact
vaccines are awesome there was a very
very very honestly
it's mandated medication i don't like
yeah you don't even have to you know
make that argument
look at how the government failed at
sending everyone a thousand two hundred
dollars
look at how look at how the government
fails at
the post office the dmv look how the
government fails at basic
human functions look how they can't even
you know set up a lockdown that they
can't follow themselves
you trust these individuals for your
complicated medical process that's the
first ever in its kind
luke i think i think i don't know i
think i think you guys
are are over just too much on this one i
defer
i defer to cuomo to kamala harris and
joe biden
i don't trust donald trump i don't trust
donald trump to approve this dude
you brought up ddt a little bit ago that
was can you explain
well well before i do that i just want
to make the point the government can't
even
figure out how to send you a check they
can't even figure out how to test people
you know they were sending checks to
foreign citizens
exactly that's amazing they can't get
that right they figured out this
complicated
four-layer schedule that people still
didn't get the i know individuals that
still didn't get the checks
and now you trust these individuals to
do a complicated medical listen
they're going to have to do multiple
times yeah listen listen listen
the likelihood in my opinion that this
vaccine comes out
and then we see some like it's either a
conspiracy or it causes widespread
problems i really don't think that's the
case
i think the vaccine's going to come out
it's going to be everyone's going to be
fine why do you think
that like how how how crazy would it be
that like they wrote this vaccine and
then everyone turns into a zombie or
something it's not going to happen
people are going to be fine it's it's
it's it's it's
you don't know the long-term effects
there was never a vaccine like this ever
in medical history so this is a first of
its kind
new type of vaccine that again we don't
know ten years
rna vaccination it's it's really simple
as this
if you trust your doctor your doctor
knows best for you me personally
i'm gonna chill for a little bit just
like joe biden and kamala harris and
cuomo said
it was cuomo who came out and said i
said that's actually a really good idea
he said i'm gonna wait a little bit
and i was like i trust cuomo on this one
no no you know my plan is
i i think when the vaccine comes out the
first people that need to get it
absolutely this is a win-win case is the
politicians give it
to all the politicians now and now if
they become
sick and something bad happens to them
they won't they won't be
politicians and they're they're not and
then everything whatever if they're fine
they're not gonna be okay i don't
they're not gonna get sick it's
it's that's not just it's not going to
happen they're going to give it to older
people first
no no they're going to give it to the
people that took the trials first the
the double blind trials
and then they're going to give it to
medical professionals next right right
then they were saying then once it's
once the the essential workers it goes
to the most vulnerable
i think it's going to be fine i think
we're we're talking about
a covid which has a survival rate of
like 99.9 percent
it's 90 it's 97.5 for people above 70.
we we've i think what people need to
understand too about
the rapidness of this vaccine trial it's
it's it's bipartisan it's it's i don't
think there's a
look but there's a lot of malarkey
involved do with it as well the placebo
is not actually a salient placebo like
like it's supposed to be it's not
something that
it's it's another vaccine that does have
side effects uh so
again i'm not you might be right you
might be absolutely i could be awesome
but yeah but but i think it's the best
is this in this case to be skeptical
what i'm i i disagree i disagree i think
uh we'll partly disagree like i said i'm
gonna chill and wait yeah
i was when i heard the democrats come
out and say
this is rushed i was like you know what
if we don't have
unified left and right in this country
saying we reviewed this
there's actually democrats providing the
doubt then i can be like well they're
the ones who are supposed to be cheering
for it
so i'll chill out but here's what i'm
saying we've been developing vaccines
for
a long time we've got a the coronavirus
is uh covid is another in the long line
of chronoviruses we've dealt with
i think i think here's what i think i
think it's gonna be fine
i think it's gonna help a lot of people
it could be awesome it's a it's an rna
of actually i just don't like the idea
that they're saying it's a mandate i
don't like the idea that ticket ticket
mastered said
we're going to put the symbol on your
tickets or that quanta said you can't
fly unless you have it going to foreign
countries and getting vaccinated
if you don't want to get sick you get
vaccinated but you have to get vaccines
to go to some country for some countries
for some reasons
dude i'm i'm i'm i i got a i went to
venezuela
and i got like five or six shots i was
there i'm fine i'm trying to find it i
didn't need to do
shots so but i don't know maybe i went
later after you
so you went uh i just show him a card i
did not i had a vaccination card uh i
would have printed one out
i got i went to the doctor and and and
he was like
we're going to do you know here's how
the the yellow fever one that hurt
yeah it goes sideways into your skin
very slowly because it has to go into
your skin for it to work and i'm like oh
it wasn't that bad subcutaneous yeah or
something like that so that
but but uh this this was this was eight
years ago
this new vaccine is kind of interesting
because the way a regular vaccine works
is they'll inject you with a little bit
of the virus or whatever to get your
body to produce
that's what an accident is well these
new ones don't they don't actually
inject the virus they
make your body think that it has the
virus and then it has the response so it
might be
way safer another has never been a
vaccine for coronavirus
ever sars burrs whatever there never was
so the fact that it's the first ever in
its kind i think
it's skepticism as your best friend i
think taking care of yourself i think a
problem
promo bro you wait listen listen cuomo
said
wait and then once it's it goes through
proper approval and you wait a little
bit not only that i'm gonna do a little
bit more than waiting hold on hold on
you guys need to realize too you're not
getting the vaccine they're not gonna
give it to you we are strapping young
virile men they're not gonna well young
ish
they're not gonna give us the vaccine
anyway so what are you worried about
depends if
we're in the chinese-made fema camps uh
but but do you know about the 1976
wine flu vaccine and that entire fiasco
no uh
people lydia look it up uh the swine flu
vaccine
the the swine flu 1960 um sorry
1976 vaccine yeah that happened where
the government 50 years what was the
situation um
well there was allegedly i don't know
the exact details of it so i don't want
to speak out of hand
but it was another situation where there
was supposedly this this you know deadly
virus going around
the government forced this vaccine which
caused irreversible damage on a lot of
individuals
and then they covered up and lied about
you but do you really
think like i i don't i now whether this
is by accident
or whether it's conspiracy we don't know
but i'm saying historically when
something is
first of its kind we don't know what
we're getting into i think it's best
to you've got nothing to worry about you
know why you can you can be skeptical
that's fine i'm totally fine with that
but the first like you mentioned it's
gonna go to the people who already have
the trial right yeah then it's gonna go
to medical professionals
then it's gonna go to the most
vulnerable so you've got nothing to
worry about
and the people who are most vulnerable
got nothing to worry about either
because like a lot of these people are
older already and they're like i could
die from covet or get a vaccine
whatever get the vaccine and guess what
then you'll know
when the older people get the vaccine if
something bad happens because you're not
going to get it for a long time
they they were saying on the news that
young people are like they're not even
on the list right now of priority
like people who are under uh i think 50
not even on a priority list at all
because they're like we're not worried
that the survival rate is 99.7 or
whatever
once we take care of the vulnerable
we're probably going to be fine you're
probably not going to need
to vaccinate like 60 percent of the
population to have hurt immunity
i think it was 80 i think that was the
exact term but i i look i'll tell you
this i don't trust
big big corporations who are driven just
like
i mean nobody can they make profit and
they can't get in trouble for it
for what's that law that got passed that
says the corporations can't be sued for
vaccines well
there's a specific uh order that right
now
vaccine companies when they're making
the coronavirus vaccine there's no
liability
at all they could kill 100 million
people and there's no liability come on
no literally and there's already similar
laws with other vaccines
in the united states because they
wouldn't the argument is they wouldn't
produce it if there was too much risk
i just i just maybe it's normalcy bias
that's it's it's not going to dude i've
heard this crazy conspiracy theory
that hiv was introduced to the
population
mmr vaccine in the 80s have you guys
heard that if we really wanted
to deal with this thing we we would be
talking about zinc
vitamin d sleeping eating a proper diet
exercising but we're not hearing
any of that i'll tell you all vitamin d
you want you want to write them in you
want
i'll tell you what i think i'll tell you
what i think i don't know what i think i
do i think i think
kovit has a 99.9 survival rate for most
non-vulnerable people most people under
70.
i think they produced a vaccine that was
why was it mass-produced because
it was probably really easy and i'll
tell you the real motive is the vaccine
is going to be fun it's going to be safe
it's going to help the vulnerable
and these companies are going to make
billions of dollars off of something
that isn't as bad as they're making it
out to be
when when they were like oh covet it's
going to be really bad we had we had a
bad covered wave it was really really
bad earlier this year
and then it seems like we kind of got
over it for the most part things are
getting bad now
but now we're getting these weird
stories like where the woman got the
left nostril negative and the right
nostril positive
or elon musk yeah like negative positive
positive
what's happening now is they're
exploiting it the vaccine is going to be
fine because
it's based on technology they're
probably already like i know it's
happening
it's what what's really the the big
concern i have is
guaranteed no bid contracts i am not
concerned about a vaccine
i i'm going to chill out i'm not going
to even get it for a long time anyway
because we're not allowed to get it what
i'm looking at is
the largest transfer of wealth in the
history of the planet the vaccine is
part of that
guaranteed revenue from the government
that's our tax dollars
and printing money devaluing our
currency being sent to big
pharmaceutical companies
the shutting down of our small
businesses and money going to big
corporations
i think the the the arguments about
vaccines and the fear over it is is the
wrong direction
i think you're right about that no no i
agree the largest transfer of wealth
that's happening right now
is the big issue is the big elephant in
the room that people need to
and that's great and i'll tell you what
the problem is when we when people uh
when even we do we talk about vaccines
and we're like oh but these corporations
it's going to scare people into not
taking like not getting the medication
their doctor would recommend no we want
them to do that
i think that's the wrong direction i
think the creep the creepy thing is
our government said we will guarantee
you two billion dollars
if you do this and they're all just
going like hot dog let's do it
our money guaranteed to them well people
get the vaccine free of charge sure
what's happening is covid is being used
an excuse right now by a lot of people
to destroy the economy and this is just
one more aspect of what's destroying our
economy you were saying something about
federal reserve bailouts earlier what
was that well
right now when we're seeing uh huge
hedge funds that are connected
to ben bernanke timothy geithner and all
these other top
big bank officials we're we're seeing a
large
swamp of of money that's being sent
directly to them uh for these larger
kind of bailout packages that have been
happening
months ago specifically during the
summer in order to make sure that you
know the stock market keeps going
there's a huge amount of liquidity just
being directly pumped
into these large hedge funds these large
banks
that again always have their losses
socialized their profits they're
privatized and this has
this is happening on an extreme level
record
number of levels especially right now in
the united states especially with the
federal reserve especially
with wall street banks that are just
literally at the teeth
of the federal government right now
sucking off the wealth of the us dollars
so all the
devaluation is kind of getting masked by
the shut the government the
economy shut down so people can't tell
that there's mass inflation from all
this
financial this money if you look at if
you look at you know
when you go to the grocery store you see
prices
fluctuating you see prices change and
they have been changing throughout the
years we haven't even noticed it
if you look at the cost of you know
silver a couple decades ago
what it would buy you compared to what
it buys you now there's a huge disparity
there is a huge difference and i think
it's absolutely
clear that what we're having as a
financial economic system is this
fairy tale tale world where there's
a witch behind the screen and it's
literally imaginary make-believe land
where we have banksters just pressing
zero
given it to themselves in this private
quasi system
called the federal reserve just
rewarding themselves for absolutely no
reason at all a lot of these people who
are getting money
aren't doing anything they're just
cycling around zeros in their computers
and that's supposedly something that
we're supposed to pay for that's
something that
they're getting profit off of if you
look at wall street if you look at the
larger financial game it is
rigged it is rigged by the very powerful
that are
making money hand over fist meanwhile
everyone else is struggling to survive
and that ponzi scheme that game is
unfolding and it's playing out and
there's going to be some severe
real consequences especially with these
lockdowns especially with these resets
that are going to be astronomical the
rich are getting richer the poor are
getting poorer
to extreme levels where our society is
totally going to be flipped upside down
and it's going to be something that we
have never seen before
it's time for super chats it was time
for super chats a while ago yeah we
gotta do super chats good conversation
jacob lloyd says with how michael flynn
was railroaded with the extra
extra judicial prosecution by the fbi
and judge sullivan
i can see why he would share the tweet
if it's possible you guys should have on
viva frey
covid lockdowns yeah canadian hear a lot
about viva
you should uh smash that like button if
you haven't already and subscribe
let's see eric crouch says he doesn't
look like putin
bill maher totally yes i get that a lot
too bill maher putin
assange oh so if you could be aggressive
had a love child i'd love to give all
you guys
ramen no bra says this guest as a young
bill maher talks like him too
thanks for having the show guys stay
safe and take care heck yeah that's
funny
i get that a lot is it the the jewish in
you are you jewish
no i'm not is that is that like a
off-color question
yes what if you and bill maher have
ancient ancestry in common
yeah he could be i don't know what's
where is he from los angeles right well
he lives there
like what's his ancestry um nope no idea
that'd be a good show you and bill on a
guy we should have one
will jay says luke is a beautiful and
amazing human being we love you
that's how i start my show usually i
just scream grendel hall says so tim
what would have to happen before you
left your bunker to use a weapon to save
the constitution
i honestly have no idea i have no idea
i've thought i've i've had
i've had conversations about stuff like
this and like talked about it
as what's what's the best outcome should
the we just enter the tpp and give away
all our jobs and just slowly boil
individuals take responsibility for
themselves move out
away from the communist big inner city
crap holes start farming start taking
care of themselves start building these
centralized communities
like they have in new hampshire with the
free state project which i want to talk
about
extensively especially with my survival
training and all this other stuff but i
think we need another episode just to
even talk about that you got an rv
basically you got an rv and you decided
to travel the world
travel and i'm trying to do survival
trainings all throughout the united
states yeah
evan messinik says sun tzu quote be
extremely subtle even to the point of
formlessness
be extremely mysterious even to the
point of soundlessness thereby you can
be the director of the opponent's fate
antifa's playbook very interesting a lot
of people mentioning viva fray viva fray
is
awesome if you haven't definitely check
out viva phrase youtube channel it's
v-i-v-a-f-r-e-i
let's see warnie warren says hi tim look
forward to the new stuff just wanted to
highlight china tweeting fake images of
the australian military killing afghan
kids
yup j mack says funny luke is saying
this i was just telling my wife
that the schism is too great between
political factions and it's possible the
only peaceful path
is a split make very i'm telling you
make china very happy
it wouldn't be peaceful though all
depends we could still keep the military
but just people just go to the side that
they want to be on
people were yelling the whole time
saying luke was talking too low his
microphone was not enough kept adjusting
it
i'm sorry everyone i failed let's see
conspiracy and linda yeah trying to mute
bryce lane says you're in the middle of
the usa in southern missouri
stop saying nowhere nowhere is a safe
state where you feel secure recognize
your sanctuary
i love that alex jones just came on and
blurted out that we were in missouri
you know he was laughing the whole time
yeah i was like what's going on here he
was
he was like you're in missouri and he
was like looking at me smiling i'm like
what are you doing
dude yeah he knew what he was doing
i know what what dude but he was
laughing yeah and he
said like three times i'm like i get it
dude
you can say it yeah i love it
was it recognize your sanctuary nowhere
nowhere is a safe state
yeah we yeah and it says kissinger's
greatest shame was the
of uh the uh well i'll just
i'll just say what he said rape of
bangladesh the blood cables are
america's greatest failure in modern
human rights
yikes i don't know much about that look
it up timothy rhodes says tim
you're an aunt you're in censored for
youtube i've had your song stuck in my
head for about three weeks now
even karma chameleon won't cure the mind
word mind word
so when's the album come out keep up the
great work tim lydia ian and crew you
guys are awesome
uh i don't know i wanted to write a song
because so for those that haven't seen
it it's the
it's a will of the people you search for
it uh
it's a short film it's a song i wrote
and it's a story and it talks about the
cycle of revolution and why
these political like these these
anti-fuck homies are never it's like
it never ends you get a revolution then
you get a revolution but you should
check the song out
let's see maurice says what does this
guy want from trump want him to be
perfect
if a president keeps 30 of their
promises that's asking a lot
trump is just fine i can respect that
opinion i just think everyone's feet
should be held to the fire and we should
always be critical of politicians
instead of celebrating them
justin four says in toronto they
arrested a restaurant owner
sent dozens of cops and mounted police
when they walked him out of the building
it's not about the rules it's a show of
force and they're still blocking that
uh barbecue place right now there's
police officers parked outside of it
literally making sure the owner can't
come back in
still today john curry says tim yes the
police in new york city and throughout
new york state swear an oath to uphold
the united states constitution i'm going
to call them the oath breakers
these cops not all of them just the ones
who are enforcing this they're the oath
breakers
michael robles says search trump's quote
this may be the most important speech
i've ever made
yeah definitely we got to watch it's an
hour long not a cop says tim
reference police reform the people would
be better served if police chiefs were
elected
most municipalities appoint law
enforcement leaders pds should totally
be accountable chosen by the people
not elected city uh by city leaders the
problem with cities
is that there's just it's too big yeah
and so a guy runs and says vote for me
i'm a democrat and they go okay
democrat that's why that's how you end
up with aoc over and over again
she's not doing anything for her for her
community there was a famous new
hampshire anarchist
satanic um trans uh woman yeah
that won mainly because she had
republican yeah at the end of her
she wasn't a republican she was an
anarchist but people still voted for her
in the primary
respect because yeah i met her i was uh
on her show
she's uh pretty interesting and she said
why are you mad you voted for me yeah
like
what's the problem i agree it's like
if you vote for somebody you you chose
to what did you get yeah you can't you
can't
pass up that he's also part of the free
state project in new hampshire oh right
on
yeah javi jay says i don't know always i
don't i don't
always with tim's guests agree with but
i always appreciate the conversation no
lydia no peace
i'm here i'm here anthony zavarro says
hey luke i met you at a ron paul rally
and
at hammerstein ballroom i said i was a
fan you said don't be a fan be an
activist to keep it
up oh look at luke recruiting and
radicalizing people well
people need to be active i mean let's
stop looking up to people let's start
looking up to ourselves and being
responsible for
each other so it's true jt says the
problem with people leaving the cities
is they bring that same mindset they
have in the city
to outside areas that don't need
government then forcing big government
policies on independent rural areas
i didn't and when you're in the farmland
we could talk about this in the next
show
you learn a lot of rough lessons about
how
crazy life is and how you need to oh
yeah uh you know you you change your
mentality by your actions and that's one
of the biggest actions these rural areas
just need to create like an ordinance
where it's like or like a law
local it's like when you move here you
have to go through a two-week
orientation process for the housing
association
and the orientation is we drop you in
the middle of the woods and then give
you a
you know gps figure it out exactly yeah
there you go yeah i like that idea
that way we know where you are you won't
get lost you won't die but figure it out
nope you automatically become either an
anarchist or a right-wing person
yeah yeah have you ever seen the chart
explaining how people become
liberal conservative leftist it's like
uh get a traumatic injury and it's like
socialist and then it's like uh
get a speeding ticket and it's like you
know conservatory libertarian yeah
courtesy says ian check out the video on
youtube star spangled banner as you've
never heard before
mona rose expand your perspective on
bombs bursting in air
what were the bombs bursting in there
that night look up the look up the video
they were cannon fire raven says china
is following japan's world war ii
strategy taking countries
in order to fuel their military and war
effort japan near succeeded if not for
the u.s sacrificing many lives
yep ctr lee says china is the reason why
people in hong kong taiwan south korea
and japan are rooting for trump
certainly is it's the ccp not china keep
it in mind
yeah it's that weird government they got
you know keegan to chesser says in
regards to the china situation i suggest
people read
rising sun by michael crichton it is
eerily similar to how modern day china
is treated by our country
zach jacob says all right i love you ian
but saying the national anthem is
indoctrinating kids is nuts man
i don't think so i mean even the pledge
of allegiance you're
you're pledging your allegiance i've
always thought that was creepy
and we didn't you never had to say it
america is about individual freedom we
don't
we don't have to pledge pledge but that
is true when i was a kid i was like i'm
not doing it
you know you don't have to do it it's
america it's a free country you know
peer pressure though
you kind of do it
galandro glade says hey tim you should
have chris chapel from china uncensored
on the show sometime
he does a brilliant job covering china
would love to you want to write his name
and i suppose yeah
yeah he's good i like his channel sarah
says the reason the q
people were banned by social media is
because they've been advocating a global
return to the gold standard for the last
30 years
i actually think it's just well for one
thing the media was looking for a target
to go after people
but a lot of the stuff they talk about
is just like it's always over the top
never happens it's like some people you
know
look every every ev every story has a
morsel of truth i suppose
when you when it when you when you're
dealing with these kind of stories
online but a lot of people just seem to
want to live in this world where there's
something bigger happening and it's like
way more boring
you know project veritas released those
cnn tapes what you learn when you're on
these tapes these big corporate you know
people
there's not jeff zucker's not going all
right we're gonna lie about trump let's
lie and say
no they're just really dumb they're like
so donald trump is racist and today he
said something racist so we're gonna
lead with that
and it's like oh like that's exactly
what i assumed they would say they're
just dumb people
you know indoctrination just you know
echo chambers
michael tierney says what happened to
your previous guests that said they had
a list of compromised americans that
took money from china they are currently
working on that story
for scanner that was rocco and emily you
can check that out uh just at
scnr.com and they're continually
reporting on that stuff and
yeah did you did you hear that from no i
did not but i'm interested that peaked
my interest i want to definitely take a
look at that well that's rocko and emily
they they have a list of of potential
compromised individuals like 50 000
people
wow it wouldn't surprise me especially
with police officers being caught spying
for china
like we saw in new york city recently
because listen when you're when you're
making 30 000 a year as a cop and then
some guy comes along it's not even
it's not some chinese guy it's a
business a corporation we want you to
consult for us
here's what we want you to do don't you
want the money it's fifty thousand
dollars
that's what that's the way that's the
name of the game man
zfg cisco says ian read your history on
the writing of the star-spangled banner
before you open your mouth
proof of our uneducated youth francis
scott keys
um okay so are you saying the bombs
bursting in the air is not propaganda by
now he was actually
he was talking about shooting stars he
was laying in a field of posies
and there were you know people singing
kumbaya and he saw
somebody was getting shelled right it
was like artillery fire i don't know
yeah something like that
it's been a long time since i read the
history of the national anthem but i
will read the into it thank you claymore
says i was told in high school in the
90s
that the communists that communist
countries don't make money in warfare
unlike capitalism
interesting mark conway says
they communist workers slash people but
a capitalistic government
they have no wage cost overhead
capitalist or capitalistic workers cost
50 cents in the dollar
communist workers cost five cents on the
dollar wow
all right let's see rosie riveter says
luke had me at john perkins great convo
highly recommend stealth war by robert
spalding and
the creature from jekyll island uh
jacqueline edward griffin
you know jack yeah amazing author still
alive
and uh he he still releases a lot of
good work
yogi fish says hashtag occupy the media
good to see luke and tim together again
oh yeah it's been a while man well doing
a video together yeah sure
it's been a long time yeah mr tumnus 32
says tim
i think an interesting first person to
have uh to have
is robert f kennedy jr he has some
information regarding the latest vaccine
testing
and also has also has and passed
since his uncle was jfk i know you don't
like super chat suggestion but was
unsure where to send it no we do we
have to write people down but he would
be a good guest i could get you in
contact with him
justin rourke says dude they are
fighting for the schools to open because
they just passed a law that's
that that you can give kids shots over
11 years old and never have to
tell the parents that's only in
washington dc and that is creepy
julian mesta says hey tim in your
opinion at which point exactly should
people actually rise up and overthrow
the
the governor in their state great work
i've watched all the live shows
i i have no idea i i'm like listen man
that's why i often complain about myself
complaining about stuff because i don't
know
i'm i'm not a i'm not a politic look i'm
not going to be a political leader
i'm a dude complaining about things on
the internet i don't know what to say i
can tell you this though
the legal system is working right the
supreme court just sided with the
religious community in new york city
they can't just do these things marshals
will come in they like
there are several states i think
pennsylvania and ohio
not oh pennsylvania or maybe ohio and
michigan had supreme court rulings
against them
and now they can't restart the lockdown
process so they're just complaining
about it
there's only so much they can do the
problem is when people get elected like
joe biden
they get the power they can start
passing laws and it's going to be bad
for everybody
so that's why georgia is so important
we'll see how things are
we'll see what's happening you know
we'll see how things play out
uh let's see kuhn t free i'm not going
to read the full name
says they aren't going to make you take
it they're going to make you want to get
it
well most people yeah and i think you
know people are
a lot of people are going to be back i
don't care i'm fine i don't get flu
shots
whatever he's not wrong he's not wrong
yeah right right
let's see sparky the pyro says come on
guys if you're gonna go full conspiracy
go with the vaccine has nanobots that
will rewire your brain in supporting
authoritarian communism and will make
you see trump as a literal cheeto
i love it that's a better concept
microsoft's working on that one
yeah right luke howard says go buy a
damn maga hat with this please but
seriously
as a strong trump supporter i don't jive
with the left or the right
same uh same end with different means
ignorance disgusts me i believe in free
will
god himself wills it well you know i
will i will point out look
a lot of the things you know i'm saying
about trump are to get at luke
and get his ideas on if you're going to
talk about if we're we're sitting here
having a conversation about how bad
biden and obama were
then what are we going to say about
donald trump would he would he would he
be the better president
in my lifetime donald trump is for one
reason
the best president what do you think
about reagan oh i wasn't i think i was
i was alive i was two years old uh war
donald trump no new wars did reagan take
us to war i don't remember i didn't i
don't think he did
um uh i'm pretty sure he ended up oh
yeah yeah maybe you're right he ended
the cold war
tron was the iran contra no that was
reagan yeah reagan had allergies
yeah that's just pretty bad right-wing
debt squads and
bringing crack cocaine into the united
states
cocaine into the united states making it
crack cocaine that's not a good thing
so what was it reagan uh iran contra
frosted that was carter
the iran contra scandal it was it was
reagan they have that the video game uh
what's the video game with it
reagan and like oliver north isn't it
yes yes yes let's see frost
frosted flame says best guest ever luke
and tim in the same podcast i'm freaking
out
i've been watching both of you since
back in 2011 2012 much love you guys oh
cool yeah i've known luke for a decade
and we we talk and hang out periodically
you know luke's going at new hampshire
and hanging out with the uh the
anarchists
we've been to some crazy crazy places
we've been in korean singapore
fukushima hopefully we don't get cancer
from yeah seriously
uh cross your fingers guys yeah yeah sad
story the uh the woman who
led us in fukushima actually died of
cancer yeah our fixer
but she was going there back and forth a
bunch of times and she
even said herself i remember this one
surreal moment
we were all pulling on our little safety
shoe suits
these white little robes and you asked
her why aren't you putting on yours
she's
like oh i don't plan on having kids and
i was like oh yeah kyle what are we
doing here like
this was like she was going in and out
of the red zone in fukushima yeah and
like the radiation was like 200 times
background it was crazy and the japanese
government lied
a lot about that entire event as we
found the crazy thing was that when the
earthquake hit
that this caused a tsunami we went to
this guy's house where
time was frozen the clocks all stopped
at the same time
and the calendars were marked off the
same day and it was like you could see
the exact time when the disaster hit
it was sad man this this guy he went to
his house and he was talking about how
it was his
like traditional ancient family home and
it was just just destroyed now
yeah it was surreal crazy but they've
been rebuilding things have been
improving you know
that's not the you know we've been to a
bunch of crazy places but yeah
next show we'll talk about that yeah
hellish kalishnikov says tim
would be interested to see some analysis
of the dominion voting systems
corporation subsidiary and ownership
research that has emerged recently 20
shell companies later and you end up in
ukraine and china it's really crazy
stuff for sure
you see that wikileaks thing that was
going around the cable from cablegate no
no in 2010 uh wikileaks published
something called cablegate it was
diplomatic communications
one of the documents talks about
dominion and it uh uh
oh no no no i'm sorry not dominion
smartmatic talks about smartmatic and
how it was originated in venezuela
and how it was implicating all these
things and then you know talks about
sequoia and stuff so there's interesting
stuff there
not enough that i could uh that i know
about right now to uh
you know get into detail but this is
interesting nonetheless
chase blankenship says the bombs
bursting in air were part of the war of
1812
when britain was trying to take us back
over it was self-defense america was
strong
hence land of the brave home of the free
we killed all those people in
self-defense
all the native americans all the british
we kill them all in self-defense you
guys well the native americans that's
all the iraqis all the afghanistan dudes
all self-defense the british
the british empire journeying down the
white house
yeah but you're but you're in your joke
you're comparing like
actual us we revolted against
our government yeah how could you say
that we were the defenders
we were i mean yeah it was a tyrannical
government but we were defaulted against
them we
started the war you mean when they were
killing people because they tried taking
their guns we started that
the boston massacre we started the
boston massacre when the regulars shot
and killed all those guys
no dude we didn't and it was f it was
finally and listen
what the what the colonists did to
native americans is is in my opinion
not defensive dude sometimes you gotta
kill people that's the lesson that we
learned
no that's the lesson of human man
unfortunately
i think the answer is yes i oppose the
death penalty for one reason
when you've subdued and contained
someone killing them is unnecessary
but in defense and conflict these things
happen they're unavoidable and an
offense in combat
why you can't compare the us
the con like the the 13 colonies saying
stop coming here
occupying our homes killing people and
getting away with it
and taking from us we had enough and
then saying we started it
no no dude if someone's coming you and
bashing you over the head repeatedly and
then you fight back you can't say you
started it
it's different than when we when the
media lies and claims his weapons of
mass destruction in iraq
and then we send our soldiers over there
for 20 years that's
not okay i don't think it is either
standing up to a tyrannical government
when you're when you're at your house
i'll put this way
if you go to your neighbor's house and
kick the door in you're the bad guy
if the neighbor comes to your house and
is repeatedly just like graffiti your
property and taking your stuff
and you finally say stop it or else you
didn't start it
you were defending yourself from them
attacking you get it
all right let's see tilt rod says in
reference to police reform
i believe we should look at the passing
at the passing of the future
please research sir robert peel and his
pelian principles
okay shadow fenrir says hail tim and
your guest your men
you mentioned cnn docs people i won't be
surprised if they try with james o'keefe
in his recent story
oh yeah they called the cops on them
yeah they did yeah they yep
they released melania's tapes uh phone
records but now they're calling the cops
on uh
well it'll be interesting because um the
cnn calls were in multiple locations
yeah so i don't if if if if he recorded
somebody in a two-party consent state it
could because depends who the attorney
general is in that state
yep special operations equipment says
this show would be better without ian
always interrupting and sidetracking
well i i disagree i disagree
you've had you've had good ones i think
you're the most the problem is i'm in
i'm in sensor mode right now i think
i i think any kind of uh
i think that conversation is important
for the show we're not going to sit here
and just me and luke high five each
other all day you know like we need
we need conversation what's the point of
it it's a unique point of view and we
need more of those as much as possible
indeed
brandon tom says holy hell two separate
wars revolutionary and 1812.
wow dave says tim check out the
documentary hacking democracy
you can find it on youtube right now
it's one hour and 20 minutes long it was
made years ago
interesting af says ian should watch
john adams 2008.
you ever see the patriot with mel gibson
that movie is so good i
bring it up all the time i'm fatigued
man i apologize to people that are
listening i've been pissy tonight i've
been pissy like for the last week but
i'm
so effing exhausted with this
bs of trump of this
this insane people obsessed with the
political system like it's
god and and not being responsible for
themselves
freaking exhausting and so i'm holding
it together and i really care about
obviously you guys you can some of this
i'll give you some ashwagandha
afterwards and
we'll meditate yeah we'll be fine we
built the rain barrel system
yeah so we're we're we're almost
completely off the grid we're working on
it
give me a knife i'll be in the middle of
woods i'll be fine yeah so
i think i think people need to
[Music]
get back to nature yeah absolutely you
know that's understand that's what i
always tell people like if you're in the
middle
if you're in the middle of the woods and
you're bug naked but you're holding a
pointy stick
you're better than nothing you're like
one point towards like good
if you're in the middle of the woods
buck naked and you have nothing that's
that's base that's that's
zero now if you're in the middle of the
woods bug naked and you're bleeding now
you're negative
so anything in your life where you're
complaining it's like just think about
you could be in the middle of the woods
buck naked
that's like the natural state of humans
in like the savannah or like whatever
and you need a community to survive and
you have limited technology you should
really watch that you ever watch uh
ancient technologies guy no
he like builds mud huts and stuff and
like he creates like water capture
systems
yeah so cool but primitive technology
technology
i think it's hilarious how people are
just like you know you have so many
people who complain about everything and
it's like bro
you got air conditioning yeah you got a
refrigerator you got clean running water
and you can walk onto any street corner
and say the word cheeseburger
and you say it enough eventually someone
will be like i got your cheeseburger bro
and they'll give you one
not crazy we're absolutely spoiled in
the first world
our major concern is not having enough
wi-fi it's absolutely
insane and when you travel the world if
you go to places like the philippines
and india you're gonna get a rude
awakening to how the world really is
and not one yeah no one really knows
brazil go to the favelas man yeah i was
there too
it's it's yeah totally different than
what we have now ladies and gentlemen
luke will be back friday right yep yeah
right on
so uh what's your you want to shout out
my main youtube channel is we are change
i am not in the partner program i am
fully
monetized could because of the eric
schmidt confrontation but
whatever um i started doing survival
courses to offset
it's pretty cool to make sure i could
survive as an individual i did a couple
in new hampshire
if i know anyone with a gun range in the
dc area south carolina north carolina
georgia
florida or if i know any crazy veterans
contact me i would love to work with
some of you guys i worked with an
amazing
special forces green beret in new
hampshire that trained me
half of the year uh and all these crazy
things that i want to share
about you know self-reliance
responsibility being out there with just
the knife you could do it uh anything's
possible check me out
on twitter.com forward slash luke we are
change at luke we are change
right on and luke will be back for the
sequel
friday you can follow me on twitter
instagram parlor at tim cast
check out my other youtube channels
youtube.com timkastenyoutube.com
tim cast news we do the show live monday
through friday at 8pm
also make sure you check us out on
itunes and spotify
other podcast platforms subscribe leave
some good comments it really helps the
channel grow
when you go to like itunes and you're
like five stars these people are the
best then
you know that helps us because more
ratings means you know higher approval
or whatever more people can see it all
that stuff really helps
subscribe hit the notification bell hit
that like button come back and don't
forget to follow
ian yeah do follow me at ian crossland
and find find yourself
no no what you should do if all the
people that have any issue with what he
was saying you can tweet at him
so follow him and then yes tweet at me
that's what i want
and you can follow sour patch lids can
i'm over here in the corner pushing
buttons
l-y-d-s we will be back tomorrow i think
um we don't really we don't really
announce the guests in case people
cancel or whatever but it's going to be
like a funny thing it might be spicy
it's going to be spicy i guess
interesting i don't know if it will be
but we're going to have we have a good
guest
it's going to be thanks for hanging out
everybody um before you go
go into the youtube search bar and
search for will of the people tim cast
check out the song it's fun you'll enjoy
it it's a short film so you really got
to watch and pay attention there's
easter eggs and everything
and uh you'll really like it i believe
you will so thanks for hanging out and
we will see you all tomorrow at 8pm bye
guys
you